in a pre-dawn raid the fbi
searched the home of a former trump doj
official over his support of donald
trump's claims in the 2020 election and
man it just kind of gets crazier and
scarier every day
the fbi the doj they've been issuing
more subpoenas they've been going after
republicans who supported trump they've
even seized cell phone data from i
believe somebody out of uh uh the gop
chair out of nevada
basically if um
if you were concerned about 2020 and you
sided with trump looks like the
the weight of the doj is coming after
you and to me this seems entirely
political
so uh
i don't know should i just say
it's a political civil war at the very
least watching law enforcement be used
against political rivals in an op-ed for
the washington post one writer said if
the purpose of all of this is just to
stop donald trump from running again
why not just use the power of congress
to do so as if to imply it is believed
among people in media that the only
reason they're going after trump
supporters and trump himself is because
they're scared he'll win in 2024 and i
think that's basically what they're
doing trying to find any way possible to
use the 14th amendment to stop trump
from winning another term and that just
says to me like i mean it's all right
there in front of your face so
regardless of what you think either
you're on the left and you think trump
staged a coup and lost
or which and january 6th so you're you
must be thinking civil war or you
support trump and you're watching the
doj go after their political rivals so
uh
trying times indeed we'll talk about all
that and a bunch of other stories
supreme court obviously this one's
really really big just struck down a gun
control law in new york so it's a major
victory for gun rights advocates we saw
this one coming
kavanagh
stopping short
he was the he wrote in concurrence yes
yes you can keep and bear arms but you
still need to get a permit and i think
that's dumb but whatever we'll talk
about it joining us to discuss all of
this is congressman troy nails
tim good to be with you yeah joining me
the rest of you absolutely thanks for
coming do you want to introduce yourself
sure
i represent texas 22nd congressional
district i'm a freshman so i'm the new
junior woodchuck on the block but it's
an honor to serve i'm i'm a very
conservative
uh member of congress i joined the
freedom caucus but we it's been trying
times you know we're in the majority
minority up there and and uh it's
difficult when you know that uh for two
years you're not getting anything
meaningful across the aisle so uh we
have our battles each and every day but
uh i keep the faith and and stay after
it keep fighting you also were a sheriff
i was law enforcement for 30 years uh
was a share for the past eight years and
it started with my father way back then
when and uh he was a sheriff military
man older brother sheriff as well
military and then i have a twin brother
and i that joined the military as well
and we're both in law enforcement uh
it's been an honor right on thanks for
coming it should be a good conversation
thank you we got sheamus i'm seamus
goglin of freedom tunes we just released
a new cartoon today about the the woke
christian inquisition i think you guys
should check that out you really enjoy
it and if you want to support our
cartoons freedomtunes.com become a
member for five bucks a month get an
extra cartoon every week and support the
cause thank you
hey everybody
just look at you james i'm jamie kelsey
i like that the first guest
is a member of congress and i'm like i
host a podcast called a f-ups guide to
the universe uh except it's not f up
it's the one i can't say but you can get
it at jamiekilsteenpodcast.com
i am also now a pretty large part of
cass castle on youtube the vlog over
here and we're doing some really awesome
stuff and it's gonna get better and
better so check that out and uh this
saturday in new york city at the beacon
theater a place that i have dreamed
about playing since i was a teenager a
homeless teenage musician i will be
performing stand-up comedy along guests
such as tim poole tulsi gabbard cornell
west and uh mr
james o'keefe himself wow tim poole's
going to be there
oh and it's run by mines you can go to
festival.minds.com
get tickets if you can't afford tickets
uh they have a like a program to uh to
hook up uh my fellow poors
now i'm also here in the corner pushing
buttons very excited to have congressman
nails on the show with us we'll hear
what he has to say about what's going on
on the hill before we get started head
over to timcast.com and become a member
to help support our work directly in the
top right of that page a little button
that says sign up click that and you'll
get access to exclusive segments from
the tim cast irl podcast monday through
thursday at 11 p.m uncensored not
particularly family-friendly but good
conversations you'll definitely want to
check out the huge library of uh behind
the scenes interviews we have people
like steve bannon alex jones all really
good stuff you'll be supporting our
journalists and we're actually getting
started on some documentaries those are
actually really expensive to do and so
with your support as members we can we
can just keep producing more and more
and more but uh we're gonna make the
investment into these documentaries
we're gonna be talking about gun control
the federal reserve these are expensive
we're going to do them hopefully we
launch those more people see the value
in helping support teamcast.com so check
out the website but don't forget to
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
let's jump into the first story and let
me just get started with two words civil
war
yup i had to say it because everybody
was waiting for it the fire emojis are
already in the chat
fed's search home of jeffrey clark
former doj official who pushed trump's
false election fraud claims
they say clark is a former doj lawyer
who former president donald trump sought
to install as attorney general in the
days before the january 6 capital riot
as top officials refused to go along
with his vote fraud claims it wasn't
clear what investigators were seeking at
clark's home but the raid was part of
the justice department's sweeping
investigation into the effort to
overturn the 2020 elections according to
sources familiar with the matter now
what we're hearing from conservatives
and republicans is that jeffrey clark
was simply trying to understand and
investigate the claims that were being
made on the left they're saying he's an
insurrectionist who is going along with
trump's schemes
i don't think either narrative matters
what matters is the narratives exist if
you're on the left and you're looking at
this you're like yes the federal
government is going after trump and his
opponents
certainly then you think trump's tried
staging a coup and we're in the midst of
some very serious crisis or you're a
trump supporter and you're like this
dude wasn't doing anything wrong and the
weight of the doj is crushing down on
their political rivals i i happen to
think that the doj the january sex
committee is just trying to stop trump
from winning that's my opinion but
either way it looks like this country is
being completely ripped apart yep you
know i've said it once and i will say it
again in 2016
when there were accusations made that
the presidential election was rigged we
investigated the accused in 2020 when
the same accusation was made we decided
to investigate the accuser make of that
what you want
i just don't like how the left is
the anti-police state side quote-unquote
the you know anti-prison industrial
complex but if it's somebody who we
don't know why yet if we know why and
the dude did something wrong okay but we
don't know why yet and just to see
democrats blindly be like yes queen and
like so excited that just trump
supporters are being uh arrested or
searched or whatever i don't love
i would assume that clark probably knew
this was coming he probably knew it was
coming you look at what the doj has done
at the sham committee they've gone after
steve bannon mark meadows anybody even
affiliated associated with trump anybody
that was texting with him uh tweeting
with him even days prior this is all
about trump this is that sham committee
and it's an illegitimate committee quite
obviously uh jeffrey clark i'm pretty
sure he was subpoenaed and he he uh
pleaded the fifth
so i wonder if this is retaliation for
him refusing to to actually answer those
questions because you know what the
january 6 committee is doing i'll tell
you anybody who's testified for for the
january 6 committee you've been played
you watch the videos they're putting out
they're pulling quotes out of context
that's what they wanted it's a
non-adversarial committee there's no
cross-examination so they're just
getting people to say whatever they want
they're taking interviews with the trump
sphere and getting out of context it's a
show trial it's a sham
and now they're using the way to the
federal government to crush anybody who
is supporting trump and it's all
one-sided because there's no republicans
on it yeah exactly so yeah mccarthy
asked me to be one of the five and i
wanted to be but for your listeners you
need to understand that this is the
first time in the history of congress
has a speaker ever rejected a minority
leader's picks to be on a [ __ ] committee
it's never happened before she didn't
like jim jones she didn't like jim banks
and some of the others so we're not on
it but we're doing our own thing because
i think it's a i think it's clearly
meant to manipulate people who don't pay
attention so they go it's a bipartisan
committee because we have because we've
got lincoln yeah right
you know what i love
i feel like if we're talking about
actual political arguments the real
factions are libertarians and
conservatives
because liberals are just saying
whatever random crazy nonsense i just
don't even understand they're like liz
cheney's great i'm like what yeah you
hated the chinese where are you what no
one in the cheney family has ever gotten
us like hyped up on fears of terrorism
or anything like that to strip people of
their civil liberties i don't think we
have anything to worry about here
wow the apple doesn't fall far from the
tree huh yeah if you've been watching
the hearings in in liz uh the first
hearing 20 minutes pretty sleepy
she must have a serious crush on trump
because she mentioned his name over and
over and over again but truly i think
what it is she despises him she thinks
about him when he she wakes up and and
when she goes to sleep she's thinking
about because she despises him everybody
on that committee they hate him and i
believe tim you're absolutely right this
is about trump in 2024. there's no other
reason for this of course i can't talk
about inflation and gas so it's all
about january 6. and i think it's having
a
sadly a little bit of an impact and
maybe that's why you're seeing desantis
numbers improve a little bit yeah well
you like desantis though i'm not saying
he's not a good guy i'm just saying that
i think that as they as they continue to
do this it's all one-sided and you keep
it on keep it on i was watching ms lsd
the other day and
and cnn and that's how you saw trump
trump trump's name on it so they're
trying to convince the american people
it's like they think he's still
president or something yeah yeah it's
been two years man go home blue and on
bro yeah
they think he's secretly still the
president i gotta say i agree with you
and you would uh you know it's
unfortunate because like you said it is
having something of an effect but if it
wasn't you'd almost just call it a weird
group therapy session they're all just
getting together to vent about how much
they didn't like trump and he was bad it
just seems like a very emotionally
satisfying thing for them rather than
something serious people are engaging in
for good reasons they're just all trauma
bonding yeah really this is uh so robert
barnes was on he was saying he doesn't
think they're gonna actually criminally
charge trump or even do a criminal
referral because if they do then then
it's ron desantis
but what they want to do is demonize
trump enough to where they'll have
something to campaign on so come 2024
trump comes out and he's like you know
i'm going to be running again and then
they're going to be like remember all of
that crazy stuff we showed you in the
fbi oh don't vote for that guy he's oh
it's the end of days
that's what they want right
it's russia 2.0 right exactly that i
wanted to ask you about that which is do
you think your constituents cause when i
go on twitter and you know the people i
follow are
a lot of them are
famous hollywood people or people on the
left still
and even my people on the right like
everyone's kind of talking about it do
real people care about this or do real
people just want to talk about the
economy like are there
working poor constituents who are coming
up to you talking about january 6 like
is it an issue that affects real people
right now i think the i think when they
uh the people that talked about it they
said there's very few people watching
this stuff listen they cannot talk about
inflation they can't talk about gas
prices but the mom and dad and everybody
else that's paying five bucks for fuel
that's what has that's what's on their
mind the food all of it the inflation
eight and a half percent so what else
are the democrats going to play right i
mean this is i mean really quite
honestly they're pretty clever about
this right let's just talk about january
6 because we can just beat trump every
day beat him beating beating beat him
because they don't want him coming back
in 2024. now i hope he comes back
because i think he'll be the 47th
president if he comes back he will be
lost can you imagine i
don't i do
coming back can you just imagine like
being at a gas station
and then all of a sudden you hear
someone just yell out and anger like
guys a run and you're like oh man you
must have saw the gas prices and you
walk over gas prices no no i'm watching
the january 6 hearing it's that viking
guy
like uh shaman
we came so close to losing it all that
day
this is this is so hysterical the entire
narrative he's the sitting president of
the united states at this point has
complete control over the military right
he's the commander-in-chief and his
attempt at an insurrection is to like
vaguely dog whistle that people enter a
building without weapons
yeah basically it was what if anything
we learned he's really bad at
interaction
so we should all feel we should all feel
safer for a third term like yo homeboy
tried it and he was not good at it
second
you know they pretty clever too because
they they show the worst few minutes of
footage and they'll show law enforcement
officers get hurt and there's not a law
enforcement officer across the country
that that would support any law
enforcement officer getting hurt and no
and if you assaulted a law enforcement
officer that they go to prison not jail
go to prison lock them up and i think we
would all agree with that yes but i tell
you something when
i give tours of that capitol today and i
gave it last week and when you go
through that beautiful statutory hall if
the individuals inside that building
wanted to destroy that building they
could have there's monuments everywhere
there's paintings they could have
destroyed it but they chose not to
because most of the people inside that
building didn't do anything wrong they
were there they shouldn't have been
there but in quite honestly they
shouldn't have done they didn't do
anything wrong one guy got acquitted of
all charges
so a video showing the cop waving him in
yeah yeah well and it's true i mean
there's a nuance right you did have
people on one side of the building who
were rioting who broke the doors down on
the other side of the building the
police removed the barriers opened the
doors waved people in those people
didn't do anything wrong
the people who broke in and were causing
problems did one one guy tried claiming
that he was let in and there's a video
of him climbing through a broken window
and they're like nah
i don't think something like he's like
they texted me said smell for the pie
then punch with cover your fist with a
bandana punch it
i want to know if they're going to
charge the dog i mean triumph the dog
now with online oh that's right no one
charges triumph my point is like even
even when you look at the people who did
break the law who should be prosecuted
it still wasn't an insurrection
well this was kind of maybe this is a
stretch to him but this was you know
occupy is you had normal people marching
peacefully which is our right to do and
then you had people destroying property
and those are very those are two very
different groups of people of course
well
with january 6 it is fair to point out
is it the capitol building and there was
an effort to count the electoral votes
so it's bad that gets disrupted that
that puts it on a special level but it
was a riot it was a riot and a really
really bad one right and and there's and
and there's questions about security and
and how we should be handling this
but the funny thing is uh on january
20th 2017
hundreds of black-clad far leftists
romped through dc smashing windows and
setting fires attacking people and they
were all arrested and they were almost
all of them were acquitted except for
the people who actually pleaded guilty
because they didn't immediately they
made a mistake yeah a bunch of people
said no matter what not guilty and then
the the progressive lawyers and legal
apparatus were able to get these people
out lawsuits were filed and the city
ended up having to pay the people they
arrested some of them
and uh one of them i think was a
journalist
so
it's funny when when the far left
rampages through dc during trump's
inauguration government doesn't care but
when you come to the government's house
all of a sudden they're going to put the
boot on you it shows you who they're
really willing to protect it's not you
it's them but only sometimes when you go
to the government's house right because
we cannot forget the 529 539 yeah where
were they they
surrounded what was it 1500 uh federal
agents 150. i'm sorry 50 yeah yeah
look i'm charging 150 million
[Laughter]
yeah 150 uh federal agents were injured
they surrounded the white house the
president literally had to retreat into
a bunker and what was the response
laughter people were laughing at the
president
is do the republicans have a plan on
holding a 529 uh commission select
committee to uh i don't believe so no
well so but you know about 529 don't go
ahead i don't the uh thousands of far
leftists ripped down the barricades in
front of the white house
tried tearing the fence down
set fire to a white house guard post set
fire to st john's church the president
was ushered into an emergency bunker out
of fear for his safety
and
uh journalists were injured 150 officers
got injured throughout the protests
there is a there is a photo from for an
aerial photo of dc showing fires all
over the city
it was it was so much worse than january
6. but i got to tell you man troy you
see i think the issue is the democrats
they play offense they hold these
committees republicans don't do it why
don't why don't the republicans announce
a select committee on on 529 and start
bringing in people filing subpoenas i
think what you're going to see is once
uh we take over and we will take over
the house in january there's no question
about it and i think leader mccarthy has
stated that he's going to obviously
form some select committees i think
we'll be looking in the hunter's laptop
and and covet issues afghanistan that
dismal withdrawal
and and obviously the southern border
fentanyl so i think there's going to be
some communities established i think
that judiciary and oversight and
government reform are going to be very
very busy uh for the next two years just
looking at some of these things but as
it relates to the 529 i'm not certain uh
but i i you know it it's sad i mean
january 6 was a difficult day i was one
of the last guys there uh you know
protecting that chamber having actually
conversations with the individuals on
the other side so uh it just said and i
think the american people look at that
it was a black eye on america i mean we
got to be clear he's a black guy but it
was not donald trump that brought those
people inside that
i got a tough question for you yeah
will you support the impeachment of joe
biden after the republicans take over
the house without question yeah there
you go without a question i thought it
was gonna be a hard one no no it
wouldn't be and it wouldn't change that
was in fact the easiest question
no my orcas needs to go you need to get
rid of some of these others because i've
been down to the southern border i'm
going to go deflect onto the southern
border but i've been down there my orca
is telling the american people the
southern border is closed no it's not
i'm down here in the water with griff
jenkins from fox news and there's people
walking right across so don't tell me
and then don't stop lying to the
american people
sorry i think he should be impeached
over ukraine i think you guys need to
launch an investigation into those
dealings it's remarkable how donald
trump got impeached
over uh
he was impeached over ukraine great i
believe right that was that was one yeah
the phone call
what biden was doing and it was it was
it was clever
the the democratic establishment and
obviously the neocon republicans who
work with them
were able to take what joe biden did
stick it to trump and use it to impeach
him they said donald trump engaged in a
quid pro quo with the president of
ukraine when what actually happened was
in my opinion when you listen when you
see the transcript and you hear about
what trump was saying it sounds like
trump didn't really know what was going
on it sounds like trump watched fox news
and then saw some video where joe
biden's like i said you're not getting a
loan guarantee a billion dollars unless
you fire the prosecutor well sob guy get
fired and then trump's like what's going
on and then he calls him and he's like
what was that video but free look at the
transcript he's like what was that video
about and he's like look into it and
that was it and they were like impeach
him why
joe biden
went to ukraine when the u.s government
approved a billion dollars in loan
guarantees
he told ukraine and bragged about it by
the way
if you don't fire the prosecutor victor
shoken i will block these loans and the
president of ukraine told joe biden you
can't do that you don't have the
authority and biden said call the
president see what he says the man
admitted to having no authority to to
acquit pro quo gloated about it laughed
in a room full of people
turns out victor shokan had a dozen plus
investigations into barisma
where hunter biden said on the board
getting 83 000 per month
now i'm not accusing joe biden of having
done that for the purpose of protecting
his son i'm saying it just so happens
the prosecutor was investigating a
company his son worked at made a lot of
money from here's the best part
according to hunter biden's laptop they
shared bank accounts so that means the
money that was coming into hunter biden
joe biden had access to they also shared
phone numbers i look at that and i'm
just like how do we not have an
investigation at the various i'm not
saying joe biden's guilty i'm saying
that's beyond probable cause to be like
maybe we should investigate what
happened here i'm just realizing me and
my father are not as close as we should
be
that sounds awesome
but this i mean and that's exactly why
the media covered it up right and that's
exactly why it was suppressed by all the
major social media companies we we we've
had other uh republican prospects you
know i've asked about this i'm like well
you know when it comes to impeachment
we're gonna need this that you're just
like we're doing it really appreciated
that actually no issues with that at all
hey can i quite honestly we gotta wait
till i mean i really want him to be the
democrat nominee in 2010 i know i was
just going to say
we
need sleepy joe to be there i saw you
try to run and pick him up when he fell
off his bike just like come on buddy you
got this you got this
can i i just want to backtrack to
january 6th because i actually think
it's really interesting and i've
obviously i've never talked to anyone
who was there where
you're a republican so you're on the
side of a lot of the people who are
there
you're from law enforcement so you have
to gauge and assess threats and protect
people um i i assume even when you are
not wearing that badge you still take
that
um very seriously
what in god's name was your
mindset during that like what what were
you
thinking what was the mentality did you
really
feel threatened were you in law
enforcement mode were you in like what
is this political you know did you take
it lightly what was going on through
your head
great question jb it was covered so it's
not like they were all 435 of us on the
floor right there were many up in the up
in the in the gallery area as well and i
was there back towards the center on the
right side and the center and we were
going through the objectives of arizona
and then all of a sudden you know
there's no televisions on the house
floor they've got some in the cloakrooms
in the back but then all of a sudden i
started getting some text messages and
stuff from family and friends and then
all of a sudden i saw a bunch of capital
police rush in uniform non-uniform yeah
and then one guy said the capital has
been breached capital's been breached
we're locked in we're not going anywhere
so i'm back at the back there and
there's they're trying to get members
out and then all of a sudden they
started banging on those center doors so
if you see pictures of me in that blue
shirt i'm that guy in that blue shirt
you're like this is white house down
it's happening and then all of a sudden
they broke the windows they broke the
windows and then it got a little bit
ugly yeah yeah yeah did you know who at
this point were you in
just defensive mode were you trying to
figure it out no i didn't know i mean i
i all i did do know is that that that
some others put some furniture in front
of those doors to make sure that they
wouldn't get through yeah they broke the
windows and then i was eyeballing a kid
on the other side a young man and then i
started having a little conversation
with him because you see in all these
pictures these capitol police officers
have their guns drawn right and and so i
i thought we cannot have this i mean
people are going to get shot if we're
not careful so my job my law enforcement
background trying to defuse the
situation yeah and we did it and and and
nobody entered uh the capital police
said you got to get off the house floor
i said i'm not leaving i'm not leaving
my brothers and sisters in blue so i
stayed there till the end cool
good for you
that's it not not worried about
i mean
were you worried at all about your
safety like your life now my wife's a
little upset but there's the picture
remember what kind of booth joy yeah you
see that guy yeah yeah i mean to be fair
me and uh the congressman almost had a
wrestling match downstairs before the
show and i was like i trust this guy can
handle himself we spotted each other's
cauliflower here you saw my ear jamie
you said i you backed off
i spotted the threat before you spotted
my ears and then you were like oh boy
and then we became friends that's great
yeah this is uh this is it right yes
yeah hey look at that that's me my wife
said god baby i didn't know you were
that receding that much at ball here
but no we were i tell you i applaud the
capitol police officers there with me
though i mean they did a good job they
maintained composure they did not fire
when that glass was broken and initially
we thought it was gunfire because i'm
i'm ducked on it wow and then
immediately within seconds there was
another guy said i don't think that was
gunfire because they'd have hit me i
mean it i wouldn't be here today one
officer did fire yeah well and that was
about probably 10-15 minutes after that
photo yeah um and that was off my back
right shoulder and in the speaker's
lobby and that was lieutenant byrd and
i've been a very vocal critic of that
shooting i've had officers shot and
killed and and i've had officers shoot
and kill people uh so i know a little
bit about uh you know self-defense and
use of force and and he he should have
been charged with that he never went to
a grand jury ashley babbitt was murdered
in our nation's capital on january 6.
will there be an effort on the do you
believe on the part of republicans or
yourself to to investigate or to to get
an indictment or anything like that well
i would like to i think we need to
continue to talk about but i don't think
there's going to be a lot of energy
to move down that path i've been one of
maybe two or three or four uh in the
house that has actually addressed this
issue we tend to like the freedom caucus
you know you look at uh right now with
most republicans and it's like they just
want to get by they want to do they want
to they want to do the bare minimum just
get by get through the next day they'll
forget about it when they forget about
it right now one of the big issues
that's really got me fired up is uh
so i'm a resident of west virginia
that's where i officially live and uh
shelley moore capito the senator
republican has signed on to this uh gun
control legislation and she's a
republican in west virginia second most
trump supporting state in the country so
i'm a little bit upset about that and
that's the problem we had we have 14
republicans in the senate supporting
this ridiculous bill
coming to the the aid of democrats who
want to strip strip us off our rights
you know what bothers me is we never see
the inverse we never see democrats being
forced to negotiate with republicans on
easing gun gun restrictions and bringing
about gun access so that really you know
i don't know that that
hurts me i mean republicans are expected
to
hold the line and compromise a little
bit and then hold the line at its new
position whenever a republican actually
tries to bring things back to the way
they used to be or conserve as
conservatives are supposed to they're
called an extremist or a radical
yeah
well
i don't know what what are your thoughts
on the gun stuff you're right there are
14 senators in in one of our senators we
have two obviously uh from texas uh john
cornyn and ted cruz and i know that uh
john cornyn i think mcconnell asked him
to kind of help lead that effort and try
to find some unity or compromise uh uh
with it with the other side one of the
democrats compromised yeah well i'm just
letting you know that uh corner we had a
uh
our big state convention was last week
and senator cornyn spoke at it and they
booted him up pretty much right out of
the room so i think he's he's having a
difficult time right now i mean uh
they're liars
shelly capito said that uh we
this is not about red flag laws we won't
allow that the bill's literally got a
whole section on red flag laws and
funding it they just they're just
spitting in our faces and then telling
us it's raining what do you think um
and i'm asking all of these serious
questions maybe because i'm surrounded
by ian's crystals and i'm trying to
bring unity uh to the country but
what are your thoughts on
i feel like democrats and republicans
they
never come together to talk about hey
how can we together
help with these shootings these mass
shootings or what can we do to prevent
them or what are better law enforcement
tactics obviously we just saw a complete
disaster happen in texas
and what ends up happening is it becomes
we want to take all your guns don't take
my guns and we stop talking about
people's safety right and so you again
coming from law enforcement i feel like
whenever republicans on the news
are asked about what we should do we're
not they don't really get asked about
tactics they just
have to automatically be on their heels
and defend you know
the second amendment essentially so do
you see any
sort of compromise or what would you do
with your experience um
about the shootings while maintaining
the second amendment like are is there
anything you think needs to change when
it comes to gun control gun legislation
or do you think it's more a mental
health thing et cetera et cetera i think
mental illness is a serious issue in our
country uh quite honestly just look at
everything you see on television today
it seems to be a little bit weird but
nobody wants to see what took place in
yuvaldi nobody
we all hurt if you have children you
it's it's painful to watch it i don't
even quite honestly like even talking
about it yeah but when you talk about
these red flag laws and if you look at
there's 19 states i believe that have
red flag laws in our country and some of
those states are illinois and in new
york and here in district of columbia
washington d.c and they have those red
flag laws and they're very they're some
of the most strict gun laws you can have
in the country it talks about waiting
periods and and keeping guns out of the
mentally ill and domestic abusers and
even talking about private sales
transaction 72 hour waiting periods so
they're all there
limits on how you could buy ammo and
they have some of the highest crime in
the country so i'm saying if chicago
listen gore lightfoot whatever her name
is if you can find a way to solve the
problems i mean people are killing each
other but nobody's talking about the
people being killed in chicago i
actually actually do have a very simple
proposal that uh will maintain the
second amendment rights and reduce these
shootings
father is in the home
i'm not kidding that's literally the
answer the the profile of most these
mass shooters it's no fatherlessness
uh
that's that's like a huge issue crime
outside of the mass shooting incident
incidents do you look at crime in
chicago for instance it's a lack of a
father in the home so we we need to
encourage at the very least two parent
homes we need we need dads we need moms
i mean what's so frustrating hearing
both of you guys is that
you know when i lived in the very rugged
neighborhood of park slope brooklyn i
you know all of my friends had never
shot a gun were all very vocal anti-gun
anti-gun any time there was a shooting
we would essentially just assume any
republican would rather play with their
toy guns and like save children's lives
because we didn't know anyone we never
shot a gun and then i moved to texas and
my friends were like hey man you want to
shoot a gun i was like this is awesome
and but i actually started asking
questions to green berets to navy seals
to firearms instructors and i'm 40 years
old and it was the first time in my life
and i had a political talk show it was
my job and it was the first time in my
life i even heard statistics like hey
it's not that we're against these laws
if these laws worked maybe we would talk
about these laws but i'm literally just
learning for the first time that like
nah man they don't even work and in fact
some of the places that are the most
heavily armed are the safest
let's jump to the story this is huge
news from timcast.com scotus strikes
down new york state's proper cause gun
control law
justice thomas says second and 14th
second and 14th amendments protect an
individual's right to carry a handgun
for self-defense outside the home that's
an amazing statement yes and
the reason i uh um i wanted to jump into
this story too is we're getting into the
gun control conversation
one of the statements made by alito was
that
the the the uh argument from the gun
control side
was that these laws are needed to
prevent mass shootings and he said
one of those happened in new york where
you have this law it did not do anything
that's the most frustrating thing to me
is that you get a lot of these uh these
gun control people argue for things that
already exist i had someone just sent to
me a lot an article and it was like
these laws could could end gun violence
and it was like
four things that are already in place
banning assault rifles is like
that uh did you google this before you
write wrote it or shared it right one
that was the reason i even asked the
congressman is because
you're literally seeing people on the
left just accuse if you're not pro gun
control that you
just are cool with murder instead of
asking people with experience with
firearms hey what do you as someone who
has more experience than me who's never
touched a gun what do you actually think
we should do yeah i i tell you what i
the laws are there the laws are on the
books they just need to be enforced you
know in texas now we have a
constitutional carry so you don't have
to go out and get an ltc you don't have
to go out get a license it's a
constitutional carry so people are
carrying guns and i tell you what the
crime in in houston is out of control
and people are starting to carry more
guns you're seeing up you know sales
increasing guns because if people can't
count on their government to keep them
safe george soros has is gone out there
and all these da's are in these offices
now across our country and they're
leaving these criminals out so these
people i think the american people are
starting to carry more weapons because
they say i can't count on my government
to keep me safe i have to keep myself
safe in my family and i can't blame them
because it's out of control our cities
are burning gentlemen now is that is
that working are the are the places with
more people carrying do they become
safer because of that sort of fear
tactic of
i'll tell you this when i started when i
finally moved to southern states i
certainly don't honk my horn as much
when i'm cut off because i'm like i
don't know what that guy's carrying i
understand and that's not the point it's
better to have it not need it need it
not have it but i i'm just saying that
criminals would have to kind of pause a
little bit and take a second think hey
am i going to pull a gun on that guy
because he may have one so let's talk a
bit about this uh this this ruling
uh we can thank brett kavanaugh for
not
for blocking constitutional carry
nationwide shocking he said basically
that this does not impact the existing
permitting rules in 43 states that means
if you're in a state that requires a
permit for concealed carry well they did
not touch that come on kavanaugh you
should have come out and been like the
government that the government requiring
permission for you to bear arms is an
infringement upon your right to bear
arms however he's of the opinion the
government can not stop you from having
it but they can be forced to grant
permission which in my opinion makes no
sense because if they can deny you a
permit for any reason then government
permission as a requirement infringes
upon your rights
but this does mean that it's likely
going to impact maryland new jersey it's
going to obviously it's new york
california hawaii and the district of
columbia so this means in all likelihood
these states will now have to actually
give you a permit it's already
prohibitively
res it's restrictive in terms of what
you need to do to apply for one so while
this is a good ruling the problem is
maryland is not going so here's how it
works maryland new york new jersey they
say okay you felt the forms you got the
training
why do you need the weapon
and this is what the supreme court
struck down you can't ask that you can
tell them here's the requirements and
then you got to give them the permit
because these states were just saying
why you need a legitimate reason for
this and no matter what you said they
went nope one of the plaintiffs
said
he needed a weapon because of a string
of violent robberies in his area and
needed to protect himself and they said
no
i'm like what more could you ask for if
you're famous if you're rich some of
these states will give them to you but
new jersey new york still don't even if
you're rich and famous i reject it and i
just said revenge
yeah it's not that's not a good reason
not a good thing i once saw a guy in
walmart trying to buy a gun and he was
openly talking about how he wanted to
get revenge on someone no really yeah
and then he got escorted out by the
police they wouldn't sell to him that's
good but uh so so basically what's
happening now is the next moves in my
opinion it's it's a good victory it's
tremendous but what's likely going to
happen is that new jersey and new york
will just create very restrictive
permitting practices
that's what that's what they were doing
and then they're gonna say
we can't ask you for why you need it but
we can ask you to undergo a three-month
psychiatric evaluation so once again
they jam you up then someone's gonna
have to sue and this took seven years to
get through seven years
yeah you know i've made it very clear
that i will not be supporting this
legislation coming through the senate
and it's just it's very difficult uh
you think that all the laws that are out
there if you think creating more laws
are going to keep the criminals from
carrying weapons they don't care they
don't care about your supreme court they
don't care about the chief of police or
any laws they're going to continue to
carry these weapons they're going to
continue to to to heart and harm the
american people the the people that are
out there doing good things the
criminals have the guns and they're not
giving them up now now hold on you were
a sheriff for 30 years or you're in love
with the sheriff right in law
enforcement 30. law enforcement 30s so
this is in texas i imagine right that's
right so uh you mean to tell me that you
know so one constitutional carry is
relatively new but you actually
encountered people who defied the law
and carried weapons imagine that but
that doesn't make sense
this can't be true it was illegal it was
like little johnny little johnny do you
know you're a convicted felon yes sir uh
do you know you can't carry a gun yes
sir
hmm
yeah did they read the site they do not
they read the sign they read the signs
i'm not following the little johnny
doesn't care
little johnny doesn't care and and
you're wondering we had shootings here
in washington dc here last week and it
was a 15 year old and he had a gun and
then there was one a couple weeks prior
to that he was 15 year old had a
girlfriend 15 years old girlfriend eight
months pregnant he had a gun and i'm
thinking to myself you want to talk
about the breakdown of the family right
the the the fatherless
there's no fathers in their lives and
and it's just causing problems so
that's what it is
a major issue with shootings is that
people don't have debts and the problem
is when you try and bring that up to the
left they they don't understand i
shouldn't say the left i always do that
leftists they actually like guns it's
liberals it's these urban liberal types
they they can't think beyond
single-layer issues
they think someone got shot therefore
get the gun away and it's like but you
need to understand the person who had
the gun had it illegally already your
new laws won't change so in chicago for
instance they're like
well it's not chicago's fault they're
doing the shootings they're getting the
guns from indiana and it's like
what more law could you put in illinois
if you've already got them don't you get
it
you will ban all the guns everywhere
they say they don't want to ban guns but
then that's the only argument we'll
destroy indiana well did you see the
store yesterday another big beautiful
wall did you see the store yesterday uh
a guy walks into a one of the stores
with a gun to rob the store and the
clerk the clerk had a gun and shot and
killed him and the siblings of the
robber
they were outraged on the news they're
actually on the news the sister was
saying this is ridiculous i know he went
in and robbed him but he shouldn't have
been shot he was pointing a gun at the
clerk the clerk had a gun and shot and
killed this guy so this is the type of
this
yeah i saw a simple story years ago um i
just want to make one point really
quickly about this this is one of the
really interesting and obvious flaws
with the left is
they want to be really really really
harsh on potential crime which is to say
going after people who haven't done
anything wrong because there's a
potential that they might and then when
someone actually commits a crime they
want to be really lenient about it
there do you see the the story of the
woman in the cell phone store and the
guy walks in and and she goes hi can i
help he goes yeah do you have a boom and
just starts mercilessly beating her for
no reason yeah and these are the people
they will say these are the people who
they will say uh you know should be able
to walk without bail and you know it's
so cruel that the criminal justice
system doesn't give them a second shot
but then when it comes to law-abiding
citizens they talk about restricting our
freedom so that crime won't occur it's
so backwards remember kamala set up an
account that's right for the 2020 riots
to bail out those individuals and that
was a true insurrectionist listen when
you go up to seattle and you occupy city
blocks what was it the chairs and the
shopping how was that not inside that is
an insurrection fellas without question
they were burning down buildings a
police station everything else and look
at many of them it was a mostly peaceful
fire
this is why
there i think there is a the political
factions are the cult and regular people
because
you have people who are like the riots
that burn down police stations were
peaceful they they outright say it they
write uh articles saying in defense of
looting after the ferguson writes they
were like actually looting is is
revolutionary and they're defying the
system and i'm just like you know did
you talk to any people who lived in
ferguson because they were angry about
the writing begging for it to stop and
then these progressive urban liberal
types city urban liberal types come out
write articles being like actually the
writing is good because they're they're
vapid self-interested egotists
who don't understand what's actually
going on i'll tell you in ferguson
people who did not live there exploited
the chaos and started destroying things
and looting them and the people who did
live there were linking arms saying
please this is our community these
snooty progressive hipster types in new
york not wanting to do any amount of
work to understand the situation looked
at it and said i'm going to defend those
brown people because there must be a
good reason why they're rioting and then
wrote in defense of looting
and and what it really was was criminals
victimizing a community and they
defended the criminals because they're
bad people well and i also i mean i will
never forget footage what happened to
george floyd was horrific i remember
seeing footage of
during the rioting um
two black women
begging
begging a white person to stop
destroying property yeah and it's like
hey these are the ones who
when you taurus when you hipster taurus
go back to your co-op and park slope and
all that stuff they're the ones who
still have to live here it's their
stores you're not they're not the ones
who killed george floyd they're not the
ones you know but look look when
you simply say something like i think
when they burn down that guy's bar it
was a bad thing and they go well you're
racist it's like okay dude yeah well
there's no argument they don't know how
to think outside that so we also see
this there is obviously
a huge part that class plays here so we
were talking about this with the
canadian truckers honking their horns
and literally one of the wealthiest
neighborhoods in the country all right
honking your horn in such a neighborhood
is terrorism you're trying to overthrow
the country but you go into a poor black
neighborhood and burn all the businesses
down that's just a-okay right and
justify means you'll scare all the moose
if you honk in canada let me uh let me
ask you congressman
do you think that uh should republicans
regain control of that assuming they do
regain control of the house probably the
senate should there be an investigation
into the 2020 riots maybe i i know you
mentioned there's probably not gonna be
a lot of energy towards these things
because they're old but i feel like we
need resolution there should be uh
because i think a lot of the agitators
in the 2020 rights what we're finding
out is many of these people are being
paid they're not even from the
neighborhood they're being bussed in
they're being called in they're being
paid by these organizations on the far
left to go out and do damage and hurt
our country uh if you saw what took
place here a couple weeks ago when they
when they had the leak with the supreme
court ruling the roe versus wade you saw
some of the things in in i think it was
in california some place maybe la that
seems to be the and and there were cop
cars that had windows being smashed and
i'm like the knucklehead break in that
window and that car has no earthly idea
what the hell roe versus weight is
he he doesn't he has no clue he he has
been paid they get these individuals and
they rally the horses they pay them to
go out there and spin things up and stir
things up and that's the problem you
have with the far left is there's no
civility there they want to go
immediately to violence and it's
dangerous in this country and and so
this deal coming up here with the with
this potential uh uh
with the uh supreme court with roe
versus wade i mean it's going to get
ugly i think national guard needs to be
deployed it's already gotten ugly
they've been firebombing uh clinics that
are set up to help pregnant women so so
um
they announced the supreme court will be
adding another
opinion day
tomorrow
and as soon as i heard that i was like
you got to be kidding me that's when
they're going to do it aren't they and
anybody who's ever covered riots so all
the journalists out there the the riot
squad i've been on the ground you know
the worst possible day is friday
because everyone's off work and they got
the weekend students out of school they
got the weekend
so if they do come out tomorrow morning
and say rowan casey you're gone
they may be thinking you do it on a
friday because then no one no one in the
media picks it up but the lunatics are
waiting
they're waiting with baited breath
it's going to be 10 45 that's when they
issue usually the last opinion around 10
40 and they're going to say row in case
you're gone and then you are going to
see tomorrow night if they do this
bonkers riots and then saturday insanity
and guys if you need somewhere place to
a safe to hide out on saturday and
you're in new york city the beacon
theater
festival.mines.com it's big theater
sturdy walls that's where some of the
worst orion is going to
be they're going to be like where's tim
yeah
yeah i just i'm i'm just realizing this
right now i mean we didn't know we had
this event's been playing for a long
time
we're going to be it's not just us james
o'keefe tulsi gabbard yeah uh
you're going to have a lot of people
there seth dylan's going to be there
this is the making of an action movie
yeah where it's like we are going to get
locked in and either turn on each other
or become the heroes new york city has
been like someone's going to eat the
last snickers they're going to be like
it's him he's a liberal he's one of them
i'll be like those are russian assets
and then we just keep going back and
forth this is yeah i mean they riot
they're encouraged to riot as you
mentioned one of my favorite lines that
we kept hearing repeatedly was writing
is the language of the unheard if only
we were hearing them they wouldn't be
writing and then they turn around and
they go we have to silence conservatives
or else they'll commit acts of violence
it's like well hold on a second hold on
a sec you're like concerned about
violence from conservatives so you want
to make them unheard because you just
told me like rioting is what people do
when they aren't heard so what do you
believe i just wanna i just wanna stress
this one more time like
they added an extra day to do opinions
tomorrow and it seems like it may be
like why else would they do that they
have the next week to do the final
opinions they could do it on monday and
so i'm like we're going to be in new
york and it's going to be like it's
going to be like dawn of the dead yeah
we're going to be locked in and there's
going to be like they're outside they
got the power lines and
we have votes tomorrow morning
mid-morning they should have probably
waited till we're out of here maybe they
won't do it though maybe what they're
trying to do is tease me no they're
trying i think there's like 16 more
opinions
maybe they're trying to be like we need
to get all this out on on on monday yeah
so that means tomorrow we should do
these ones then monday we can do roe v
wade the holiday weekend wait for over
the four years yeah yeah i agree maybe
oh yeah people won't be paying attention
maybe
or whatever crazy people are
the crazy people will be um but it's not
a holiday weekend it's it's a holiday
month it's maaga month that's right yeah
maga month the month of july we got to
change all of our profile pictures to
american flags and celebrate america
okay
and i'm okay with that and we're okay
with that and we grill every day
every day and then and then on the
fourth of july you have the fireworks
but yeah mug a month
i'm ready i'm not even kidding i'm legit
like we are going
to stop i ordered buddy i'm moving it
i ordered uh what did i order uh
fireworks i hope how many hot dogs did i
order 100
100
what is this yeah i think i ordered 100
hot dogs or is it 500. no it's not 500 i
think that's when i'm moving my stuff
from austin i'm going to have to change
my plans it's all month bro oh it's all
months oh we're going to be firing up
the grill all month this is awesome so i
ordered this big thing from portillo's
famous chicago hot dogs every day baby
and so we're gonna be grilling moving
here is the best decision i've ever made
yeah this is awesome
everyone's gonna be chilling that's work
maga month baby yeah we celebrate
america oh my goodness what were we
talking about i wanted to get a little
optimistic gun supreme court protesting
man i also you know it it's just
we
i feel like the the rioting is sort of
the on the street equivalent of what
happens on twitter where it's like do
you actually want something to get done
right if you actually want something to
get done you're gonna want to talk to
people you're good for example so i got
not many i've gotten and i thank all of
you listening i've gotten thousands of
new followers on on twitter and to the
podcast since i've started coming on
this show but i've lost a couple
of vocal fans of mine who are on the
left
and they would just say stuff about you
that
was hyperbolic but also that i would
disagree with and they were like how
could you be on a show with that person
and it's like hey man if you think we
disagree on that
wouldn't you actually think it was a
great thing
for me to be on the show for me to bring
a diverse viewpoint for me to become
friends with someone who
maybe i will even see my point of view
like sometimes i see his point of view
and they don't care no they will not
listen and yeah and that's that's where
i'm at so there's uh we've got this
lefty guy who's going to be speaking on
the same panel as us in uh at the beacon
theater and he had to put out a video
explaining why he was doing it
he called it a debate and so i got a
message from this like left-wing guy
that i that i'm friends with and he's
like you're debating this dude and i was
like i'm not debating anybody we're
talking about like it's a panel on media
manipulation we're just hanging
i mean i'm gonna sit there and be like i
don't know like i don't i don't i don't
like debating people i'll argue with
someone i'll try to correct them if i
think they're wrong but i don't enter
debates i don't like invite people here
to debate me i don't do any of that
stuff i just let's have a conversation
it's a hang it's a conversation but the
fact that he even had to make a video
addressing it being like here's why i'm
doing it and then people responded with
like yeah but dude it's james o'keefe
like what's wrong with you it's okay
whatever dude i don't look i don't i
don't want to live that way i don't i i
like i like being able to walk in a room
with anybody and be like tell me stuff
yes it it appears to me that the
american people can't seem to to be able
to sit across the table from each other
like this and have and agree to disagree
yes and and what we're teaching our kids
in my humble opinion when when when you
see what took place with the summer
rides in 2020 it seems like if we
disagree now we just all of a sudden we
curl up our fists and we hit each other
in the nose and i think it's it's going
in the wrong direction what are we
teaching our kids what are we teaching
these these kids to think hey if you
can't resolve you just go in there and
hit him in the nose and and 20 20 was
bad but we are one tim we are one police
shooting away uh from having an enormous
civil unrest i mean if it's if it's a
white officer that shoots an
african-american and there's any
questionable call there al sharpton has
his plane on the tarmac it's ready to go
he's gonna fire that thing up he's gonna
fire he's gonna fly to that area and
he's just going to go in there and he's
going to be an agitator it's it's it's
sad well that's not the way we should
handle things it's not even about if
it's questionable
you take a look at uh the arm ahmed
arbory case you remember this one yes
fox news conservatives republicans came
out in defense of aubry and i was just
like well look i don't like the guy i
don't want the fact that anybody dies i
like the fact that he died but the story
is just we had a couple lawyers on who
broke it down for us and i'm like okay
so this guy was a burglar like yes he's
on camera committing a burglary yes and
so these guys were told by the police he
was the burglar yes so then when they
saw him they chased after him yes and
they were told that if they witnessed a
felony they could intervene to stop him
yes
but the police told them to stay stand
down while they while they came to
arrive and they didn't listen
and i'm like okay
and then what happened the guy who
filmed it got the reindeer of his life
in prison and i'm like okay something
doesn't add up here
this this story doesn't make sense so
it's not even a question of if if it's
like i mean the ahmed arbory case
should be very clear-cut in what
happened
but they will weaponize it and they will
lie about it and they will make it
questionable well and i i i think that
just like
the left needs to keep a lot of their
people in check when it comes to
rioting when it comes to destroying
property and stuff like that we also we
do have a problem there have been plenty
of kids who have lost their life
unjustly and we need to talk about that
as well like the one i always think of
is tamir rice where it was like you have
like what a 13 year old kid playing with
a toy gun and i i think in law
enforcement i think
oh no is there something i don't know
yeah yeah don't tell me to mirror rice
is really like a 45 year old man no i
think he was uh i think he had removed
the orange tip from the gun and he's
five foot ten well but so here's what i
was gonna ask the congressman from his
law enforcement um days
is i feel like
even if it is not
racism right there there is protocol
like
unless you feel like you are in
immediate danger you want to de-escalate
if you can't de-escalate you want to go
hands-on if you can't go hands-on you
want to go with taser and then in theory
pulling the gun should be
last or am i incorrect on that well
this is what i do know yes is there's
not a law enforcement officer in america
that's going to wake up tomorrow morning
and go to work evening shift and that
[ __ ] that says i want to go out and
legally kill something i'm going to kill
a kid i want to go out there and legally
kill somebody today it's absolutely
ludicrous i think because that officer
that has to take that life they're going
to live with that for the rest of their
life even if it was a very dangerous
situation yes and the guy's pointing a
gun at you and and it's so difficult for
law enforcement today because of the
people that are mentally ill i mean you
have people that are mentally ill with
all the drugs the federal coming across
they're running around in streets naked
and they're chasing uh officers whether
it's a a small knife or even a a piece
of glass and they're running at the
officer the so the officers have a very
difficult time today and they have to
make very split you know second decision
so did you see the video actually and
jamie you see this where the news
reporter goes to the police conflict
training uh scenarios did you see this
one no and so the cop is like here's
what we're gonna do we're gonna give you
this mock weapon that you know it fired
like spitballs or something or
paintballs and they were like you need
to figure out when is the appropriate
like how to do a situation oh no he so
in the mock scenarios he kills a guy
several times and in one
he like sees a guy by a car and he's
like what are you doing and the guy
walks around the car and just pulls and
shoots and then the uh the cop goes
why'd you do that and he's like well
he was like he was just walking around a
car and he's like but i didn't know what
he was doing and i was worried it's like
the the reporter was like in every
circumstance he was given the reporter
actually killed the dude
unjustly
in one the guy just says something about
reporters though dry fair
it's like journalism
there was one moment where the guy gets
in his face like what are you doing man
get out of here and then he puts two in
his chest mockingly right and then the
cop is like what did you do you killed
him oh then everyone starts filming and
it's like okay so you guys are going to
hate me and before the audience hates me
please follow me on twitter at jamie
hillstone
send him your hate subscribe to my
podcast uh instagram at the jamie
hillstein isn't that
more evidence for one more police
training and two if you're gonna own a
gun so for me i i want to own a gun now
and i've been anti-gun but i don't want
to own a gun until i know
just like with jiu jitsu just like that
i can proficiently that can be taught
and that i can train every week
especially under stress so isn't that
also
an example of why people
should get training before they get a
firearm and law enforcement actually
maybe needs more training so that even
though tamir rice even though maybe the
toy gun looked more realistic that
you're confident enough to assess the
situation before you just open fire on
who turns out to be a kid
everybody wants to go after law
enforcement with these shootings and how
about train the crook not to point the
gun at the law enforcement horse look at
the knucklehead the other day pulled up
next to the traffic stop right did he
have an axe or something
and he went after the officer now the
officer was trying to back up do the
best he could to keep that separation
because it's 21 feet fellas well that's
that's that's the number but i think we
i think we can do both like this is the
argument that happens i remember even
when i was in super woke wokey mode when
i would advocate for women to train
jiu-jitsu people would go you're
victim-blaming it's not their fault they
shouldn't have to do anything you know
we need to teach men how not to rape and
it's like well yes we do
but also
until people stop
training jiu jitsu will help you yeah
i'll finish with this on this yeah
i said it and i'll say it again and and
that is is that
if you
comply if you comply to all the
criminals out there the ones that carry
guns they shouldn't have guns the felons
all these guys are going to go by
if you comply
you will not die
that's it it's very simple if you comply
with you will not die and when you look
at michael brown and all these others i
mean michael brown's fingerprint was on
the officer's weapon so if you're out
there fighting and holding court on the
side of the road this and that there's a
high probability something could go
wrong and it may take you it could cost
you your life so just comply if you
comply criminals you will not die
yeah a lot of these uh circumstances you
see people uh not not just shootings
they just are arguing with the cops and
they don't understand that whether
whether you want it to be reality or not
it is
if a cop is stopping you you will gain
nothing by fighting with him and talking
with him that's the funniest thing it's
like you're being arrested i love it
when i hear these activists at occupy
they were like i have not been read my
rights like
and but they watch movies and they think
a cop has to mirandize you because they
watched you throw a brick at somebody
these people know what they're talking
about you keep your mouth shut
unfortunately you know there are
instances where police have wrongly
arrested people during action by wall
street i actually filmed the cops
wrongly arrest somebody they lied in the
police report got a different officer to
sign off on it and i filmed it i want
those officers charged criminally but
that doesn't happen that to me is the
problem the issue isn't
the issue is when an officer is breaking
the law violating their out to the
constitution
but if this is what really frustrates me
too there's a video where there's like a
black dude walking in the street and the
cops are like hey come and talk to us
for a minute stop and he goes no and
they're like you you are being detained
sniping goes no and they fight with them
and they're like i can't believe the
cops did that and it's like dude
cops have a right to stop you to ask you
questions they can they can detain you
for a small amount of time it's it's the
way the thing the system goes you might
not like it i get it
but fighting with cops when they're like
what are you doing in this area is not
going to er is not going to win anything
for you you're not going to win on
activism you're not going to win on the
law all you're going to do is make
everything worse
everyone agrees yeah well it's well it
seems common sensical though right and
people will
so
i've
been thinking about this and it's
something i've
i don't think i've really discussed on
this podcast or oh no actually we did
kind of talk about this the other day
but
it makes sense in a very polarized
environment where people have very
different opinions that we're going to
end up
disagreeing on things at such a
fundamental level that there are certain
issues where we won't be able to reach a
compromise right and so whether you're
talking about abortion or homosexuality
or any of these other issues
when it comes to police these are not
matters of principle these are
case-by-case situations that have to be
investigated right if you hear a police
officer shot someone it's not i'm for
that or i'm against that it's all right
well let's look into it and see what
happened but for whatever reason we are
in a place in this country where people
will hear that a police officer shot
someone and they will immediately know
that he is guilty and not only that he's
guilty but if the person was a minority
that he was guilty and he did it because
that person was a minority there that is
insane there are stories that i think
should be pointed out but people need to
be careful not to conflate the outliers
and the accidents so there's that one
famous moment where a guy gets pulled
over black dude gets pulled over in a
van he gets out of the v he's like cops
has got a vehicle he gets out and the
cop says show me your id and he goes
okay he turns back into the car and the
cop just shoots him
he was going for something it's like
youtube probably you told him to get the
id right you have uh someone mentioned
philando castile are you familiar with
this case
he was uh legally able to carry a weapon
the cop panicked and shot him there's
another issue of like he shouldn't have
been shot but he was also smoking
smoking pot while he was driving so that
kind of mudded things up but he
shouldn't have been shot there yeah
that's not a death penalty yeah offense
they're they're the issue is
how do we deal with these
accidents and outliers
i think the challenge is we need to
actually have a sit-down conversation we
need to analyze what causes these and
then figure out is there something we
can do to make sure they don't happen
while making sure cops are safe when
they do their jobs
there's no there's not a cop that i've
ever spoken to that agrees with what
derek chavin did uh to george floyd
that they would agree with that and and
he should go to prison but gentlemen
there are hundreds of thousands of stops
made up to millions each and every month
each and every month on traffic stops
and you're going to find law enforcement
officers that that
make judgment calls and they could be
the wrong call you're going to get some
that are going to get scared you talk
about uvaldi now why do those guys not
go into that building i don't know but
but the point is is it's a very very
difficult job and and everybody should
go through what that media person went
through you know we we have police
academy training citizens please get
them it's a fats training and they go
through and they realize it's just not
as easy as it just seems like you just
so the point is is that there's very
very few uh officer involved shootings
today i mean come on when you look at
the number of contacts with citizens
today very few result in
police officers firing their weapons and
when they do they're scrutinized before
the damn bullet even hits the
you know it's just crazy i think it's
375 million interactions per year
something like that and out of that
there were i think what was it nine
unarmed black men killed in 2019 and
even that is a little deceptive right
because first of all it's possible to
shoot someone who's armed and for that
to be unjustified but also it's possible
to shoot an unarmed person and for that
to be justice justified so when you look
into these unarmed cases one of them
from a couple years ago i was looking at
was he was strangling an old lady and
then went to attack the cop it's just
insane so even if you hear the words
unarmed black man shot by a police
officer you don't know anything about
your story until you know something
about the story you see that viral video
where the guy is coming at the cop with
a knife and he's backing away for like
30 seconds going no no but then the guy
grabs his partner goes no no then he
starts shooting the guy and the guy gets
shot and he gets back up he gets back up
that that's he gets shot because he's
coming at the cop then after being shot
he grabs his partner and then the cop
gets it shoots him in the head it's like
people you know you know what i think
one of the issues is
it's the algorithmic psychosis i call it
let's say you're 10 years old and the
year is 2012
and you open up facebook and the only
thing you're seeing yeah is police
brutality videos
remember remember that song where it's
like this is what you get when you call
the cops it's like the guy rapping right
like it's a really good song but it's
like
facebook recycles those videos
because it gets clicks people make money
so then other people recycle them reddit
was doing the same thing
10 years goes by
where you're you're 10 years old
watching these videos and for 10 years
it's all you see you believe that is the
world oh bro that's what i was telling
you before that's why literally
at 40 years old it's like the first time
i'm talking to
conservatives or
law enforcement or and by the way
the all the law enforcement friends i
have said the exact same thing that you
said
about
um the george floyd murder where they
were the most horrified and i think if
we got rid of this us versus them
mentality
and then we could let
let the good cops speak up and be like
that shouldn't have happened and then
they go continue to be good cops i think
i think there are issues but i think
with 375 million interactions we're
talking about like a microscopic
fraction of of error and so there's
something else that i refer to as the
scaling problem and i'll put it this way
most of you watch if you watch
consistently you may have heard me say
it
let's say uh um iphone gives out 100
phones to these celebrities and one
percent of those phones break nobody
cares one celebrity comes out he's like
hey my phone broke and they're like oh
that sucks let's say they gave it 100
million phones and one percent break now
online trending one million tweets
broken phone like whoa all these phones
are broken the same same failure rate
so if you have
you know 375 million police interactions
the margin of er
the acceptable margin of error decreases
as time goes on
if you had 100 cops in the united states
and one percent brutalize someone that's
one cop people would be like it was just
one cop who cares i'm waiting for uh you
get 100 million cops and i got a million
police brutality stories people lose
their mind which means you've got to
reduce the margin of error as you scale
up the size that's impossible to do
infinitely and tim it seems like the
answer to this this problem we have with
police brutality
is that we're going to defund them
matter of fact not to fund them we're
just going to completely abolish them
but i think a majority a solid majority
of the american people support the men
and women
in blue it's that small group that's out
there just raising
cane and just causing problems well i
can't
oh no no i was gonna say i can speak as
someone who
you know
during the emotion of
everything that happened with george
floyd
i was listening to a lot of the defund
the police people until i moved to texas
and i started talking to more police and
police were saying hey dude we don't
like what happened either
we actually if you defund us that's less
training right and we actually need more
training and we need more resources and
what you're going to do if you deplete
us now we're working more you know
everybody on swat we're working more
hours we're understaffed it's like you
think that's going to help judgement
jamie would you do your buddy's job for
70 000 a year would i what would you do
his job the law enforcement the man on
the swat team at this point if i could
train and if i could do it yeah but
that's because i'm becoming a psychopath
i was like i would do it in a heartbeat
but but but a lot of people on the left
would not if that's what you were going
through yeah i just think people people
are leaving the industry people are
leaving the profession because just the
the criticism and all the the
anti-police rhetoric out there and then
you're going to lose i'll tell you it's
dangerous you look at some of the cities
now look at the homicide rates the
crimes going up through the roof why
would you keep down with that uh defund
the police and all that and there's that
and you won't have police protection
well i tweeted this about yvaldi i said
this is what happens when you defund the
police and then everyone was like they
were well funded you're wrong and it's
just like you need to understand the
subtlety here when the police are
demoralized demonized and attacked
relentlessly they're going to be like
i'm out no don't care i i do want to add
though
i'm a little salty on cops considering
what happened with covid because too
many cops for one i'll say a few things
cops enforcing unconstitutional gun laws
i think is a problem and during covid
cops enforcing unconstitutional edict
was a huge problem and the one thing
that was a big wake-up call for
conservatives and why a lot of trump
supporters and conservatives soured on
support for cops was because we saw cafe
owners salon owners while the dominant
game owners yep yeah gym owners uh
attila's jim when you had the democrats
releasing prisoners and inmates who
commit violent crimes and then taking
business owners and putting them back in
people got really pissed off about that
but but it in the i tell you what did
you see that though you said you saw
that in these large municipalities where
there are police departments that work
for a chief of police who works for the
mayor and the city council so you didn't
see that with sheriffs you saw the
sheriff's they're elected they the only
people wait
there could be some far left sheriffs
out there that would be doing that too
but a majority of the sheriff says i'm
not i'm not enforcing that i wasn't
going to enforce mass mandates because i
only answered to the people that elect
me chiefs of police have to answer to
mayors and the mayor is going to tell
the chief you get your people to do it
if you want to keep your job you're
going to do exactly what the heck i tell
you to do that makes it a little bit
more difficult as it relates to
municipal police departments and
sheriff's offices and who they're bosses
and but that's a thing a big distinction
there was one instance where a sheriff
in minnesota went and arrested a cafe
owner for opening a cafe but again i'm
not going to point to one case and be
like all the cops but a lot of people
were just like if this is what the
cities are doing so my attitude is kind
of like let the let the if new york want
to abolish the cops let him do it i
don't live there let the people see and
you see how it's going but i do kind of
think maybe an easy solution is cops
should be elected
like you shouldn't have a chief of
police appointed by a political
individual who then has his job held
over him we should vote for who the the
the police chief is
well they don't survive very long uh
chiefs of police tenure as chief is
because a new mayor comes in he wants to
bring in his own pe you know his own
buddy well there's always a cop that
they have to deal with who doesn't play
by the rules and he's going to retire
soon and then they get into it
i was hoping someone picked up on that i
was really proud of it and as i was
saying it i was like oh it's dying this
is very but no i um
you said something earlier about how you
think most people actually do support
the police part of why i would agree
with that is because people as spineless
as joe biden during his state of the
union address we're willing to say
well we need the police to be well
funded which is what joe biden said
during his state of the union is no
don't defund them defend them like oh
interesting yes yeah um so this is
becoming a safe position in the polls
i'm sure it always has been but it's
something democrats are even willing to
say at this point well when when people
are watching violent crime skyrocket
some dude pushed him on the train tracks
in new york oh people don't want to live
there man yeah you know it's just and
it's not just in new york city it's all
the cities crime is through the roof and
they're moving to texas
you know we gained two congressional
seats new york one california last one
we're hoping they're not bringing that
ideology
into texas i i think we should interview
them before we actually allow them
but but they're moving into texas and
you look at you know we have
constitutional carry i mean we we have
just texas is one of the greatest states
i'm proud to be from it
um
i moved from la to austin and everybody
i met was like how are you going to vote
how are you going to vote you're going
to you're going to say if you're going
to come how are you going to vote uh but
then the worst thing i saw was there's
you know there's a bumper sticker that
says uh don't california my texas and
the first time i saw it it was a dude
with the florida license plate and i'm
like come on man
you're in the most liberal city in the
whole state oh i know uh travis county i
mean austin is very very very very
different it's all just wellness
podcasters it's terrible yes there it is
so here's the issue with texas you know
everybody was telling me like you guys
should move there you guys should move
there and i was just like no way
because elon musk he's cool right but
when he moves and and builds a factory
in austin and relocates his california
employees those people are progressive
they're liberals so it's not just about
joe rogan and ellen musk it's about
everyone they bring with them and then
when uh you know jamie you end up moving
there hello you got michael malus you
get these these prominent individuals
comedians and podcasters then the
periphery of those groups are going to
come as well and then california moved
to texas right people were like no it's
good that these people are moving
because they're they're they're you know
helping texas and they're making it red
and i'm like
maybe
but what's going to happen is a
california conservative is a far left
texan yeah and they come in and they'll
they'll vote republican because they
don't like california leftism which is
coming texas and they'll make texas
moderate not republican sure
eventually i mean but but look at 2020
trump run texas by 600 000. uh you saw
the congressional race we heard i think
is texas 34 first time ever in the
history have we saw seen a a a
a
female mexican born in mexico become a
member of congress so i think many of
the just the policies the policies of
the left with the border and everything
else people are i feel pretty i think
we're going to do very very well in the
state of texas here in november it's
going to be a bloodbath i am sick of
republicans playing identity politics
yeah i'm just kidding
so what happens in 2022 you think uh by
november
it's gonna be just
like you think the polls are wrong and
it's gonna be a crazy blowout we've
never seen before a republican super
majority or something yeah i think
you'll see uh probably gaining 30 35
seats we're not running about 212 213
we'll probably gain 30 to 35 seats and
that that's that's a big number i think
i think it actually could end up being
better than uh republicans realize it
could because if the polls have been
consistently
uh skewed in favor of democrats and
right now in the generic ballot
republicans are up about three points
they're probably at 10.
yeah then you look at interestingly five
i'm sorry real clear politics has the uh
the toss-up seats and i think 28 of 32
toss-ups are democrat held
so it's just like it might be way bigger
than people realize
i wouldn't be surprised if it was less
than we realized as well i don't know
there's still a few months ago here so
yeah let's just wait and see what
happens but let's let's let's talk
beyond that though what do you think you
think joe biden's going to run again
well i hope he does i i i
i really do and i'd i'd send him 25
if anybody knows his mailing address
i'll send them 25 bucks uh she's worse
than he but i think the democrats in
trouble because i don't think they
really have a candidate right now um and
and so they got nobody that's that's why
they're so desperate to try and bring
trump back to life yeah and and i i
think right now our country um when you
look at when trump was president for the
four years i mean we didn't have all
these crisis i mean just name one or two
i mean covert was difficult yet but i
thought he handled that quite well with
the vaccine in record time but i i think
we need him back in 2024 i think this
guy donald trump uh in my humble opinion
loves this country more than just about
anything but what about what about
desantis do you think you think trump
would be better i think i think desantis
should keep his powder dry till 2028. i
mean he's relatively young man he went
mid-40s or so and he's been you know
he's a member of congress i think he's
been governor now for what four years
and and i just think in 2028 he'd be
great and and there's competition going
back and forth with our governor in
texas as well who's gonna who's gonna
get that base who's gonna move her
further right but i just think everybody
should just uh bow out and just let
donald trump come back he will be the
republican nominee and he will beat
anybody what is that i want to hear two
words from donald trump the moment he
gets up he gets inaugurated
you're fired
beautiful words
i want them to just fire all of these
bureaucratic administrative state trash
people in dc we have a lot of talent i
mean when you think of ron desantis and
the great things he's doing in florida
people love him so i think we have a lot
of good talent out there and and and we
have people for in the wings in the
future the democrats are just struggling
who corey booker i mean who do you got
the democrats are just struggling they
don't have anything
bernie crazy bernie give me a break i do
like bernie better than newsome to be
fair uh bernie if there was any democrat
i'd i'd rather have bernie but i think
bernie's a sellout so i think they're
all yeah
what is it specifically about trump
that
energizes you so much is it that he was
an outsider or is it
was it him before he ran for president
or the way he governed for four years
the way he ran the way he ran he had 14
people on that stage and he just picked
him off one at a time he's just real
he's i thought he brought a lot of humor
he was kind of funny i mean yeah
nicknames and people don't like the way
he calls names but overall
and and
when he come up would build that wall
build that wall that really energized
his campaign and and so i just think
that you can't buy him
you can't buy donald trump he has all
the money there's no special interest
going to get him and just the way he ran
the country uh he deserves a uh a third
term are you familiar with the tales
from an economic hitman that book oh
yeah so you've heard of this yeah if
luke were here he'd be able to educate
us properly but the general idea is this
guy said that you know he worked for the
intelligence agents in the uh agencies
in the u.s and what they would do is
they would go and try and bribe you know
uh
a country and say like here's what the
united states wants we'll give you all
this stuff if you're doing what the imf
will come up with loans and then if the
president or the government said no then
they would try and take out either
politically or through assassinations
and if that didn't work invasion that's
what he claimed i i think about those
stories and i'm like whether or not
they're true or not you look at donald
trump
he gets elected they didn't think he
would he has these meetings they
probably were like you know trump play
ball with us here's what we're going to
do and he went no we're doing it my way
i don't want to do it and then they try
to remove him via the you know a legal
process russia gate
that doesn't work so what do they do now
executive action now they're going with
the january 6th the law enforcement
stuff the accusations the doj the fbi
raids so they've escalated the point
where they're like we are going to use
the force of violence against this man
to stop him from running
i had to reread that book now
yeah that's crazy he's talking about
like panama stuff and it wasn't like a a
small conspiracy book it was a new york
times bestseller it was you know right
right right it was like listen i got a
lot of people they don't like his tweets
they don't like what he said they don't
like maybe some of the stuff he said
about john mccain and when he was a
prisoner of war and all whatever right
and i tried to and
just there's some other things but i've
always said i said you guys
you're not electing your neighbor and
we're not electing the pope
right we're electing the president
united states and when you look at his
policies and the results of those
policies
ukraine would be the prime example obama
went into what 2014 went into crimea
right nobody went into ukraine under
donald trump did he putin didn't go into
ukraine and donald trump now you get and
so you have you have our adversaries
that are taken and exploiting our
weakness and we have weakness in our
president today donald trump ran this i
mean just look at how he kept uh russia
in check and how he kept china in check
i mean
look at this
no invasion from russia while trump was
president despite crimea then all of a
sudden trump gets in and putin backs off
i understand so i just think listen i'm
a trump guy i i hope he comes back uh he
doesn't drink doesn't smoke i think he's
uh he's very healthy right now i've had
opportunities to visit with him a couple
times and and i think uh this country
needs him more today than ever man you
know it would help you should tell him
to come on the podcast
well i i think i think we're actually
setting that up there you go no for real
here we go yeah we'll have to go he'd
like you guys oh yeah oh yeah we're fans
we're yeah we're good thing about it is
he wouldn't have to dress up well i
don't know
i'm not wearing i used to but it wasn't
appreciated sheamus i'm just kidding
buddy
but by the way if he'll if he agrees to
be in the vlog i'm a fan yeah he gets me
that would be great
get trump to do like a simple bit i mean
he was in home alone you know
yeah yeah that'd be cool if he was in
new york um
so i i i don't uh
the other a lot of a lot of people who
are trump zealots you know they're just
like trump's the best you can do wrong
i'm like trump's pretty good he's all
right i didn't vote for him in 2016 in
2022 i did i said you can't deny the
successes he's had getting rid of the
trans-pacific partnership was the right
move every activist in the world okay
every actors in the united states were
complaining about tpp
then trump comes in and all of a sudden
they were like actually it's a good
thing and i'm like
what like during occupy wall street like
all throughout everyone's like warning
about this trans-pacific partnership
trump gets in and gets rid of it donald
trump no new wars
starts bringing our troops back from the
middle east these are good things i was
talking to someone and they told me oh
it was all it was all nonsense he tried
to be buddy buddy with dictators and
blah blah and i was like what does that
mean and they're like like him and kim
jong-un and then i said
donald trump crossed the dmz into north
korea with no security detail and
they're
yeah and i'm like that is one of the
most profound acts of leadership
someone could take to try and end a war
they could have captured the president
of the united states
and they could have done whatever they
wanted and trump walked in with kim
jong-un and walked back and i was just i
was shocked if dennis rodman can do it
i'm going to do it but i mean in all
seriousness i mean you're the president
united states
walking into what should be perceived as
hospital territory i'm like this is
amazing that's amazing i i gotta vote
for this guy and then what happened was
his second term agenda came out and i
was like school choice get rid of these
uh cult these these critical race theory
garbage stuff and i'm just like
this dude's done well i just deserves it
i talk about this all the time i scream
about it on my podcast and twitter and
all that stuff people need
principals not teams right if you were
mad when george bush had drone strikes
that killed civilians you should be mad
when obama did it if you were mad that
trump did it yeah you sh
if you thought um
you know bill uh trump was creepy with
women you should think that bill clinton
was creepy with women right joe biden
yeah with children yeah i mean there are
so many instances where and that doesn't
mean suddenly you have to disavow them
that doesn't mean you have to go from
democrat to republican republican to
democrat it just means have the
political courage to stand in your
conviction and call out your side when
your side is wrong in order to make your
side better and hold it accountable and
then we can actually have a more honest
political discourse one million percent
and i i really just want to hit on this
point i i made sort of a little joke
alluding to it but the president of the
united states sniffs children
and we're used to it like we don't think
of it as being that out of the ordinary
it's just you know it's almost become a
punchline but the president
sniffs children
he gropes them too it's disgusting you
see the picture wasn't there anywhere
like you pinched a little girl's nipple
or something what
it appears that most people too they
look him at like a grandfather figure
and they almost kind of feel for him
like this is grandpa joe
i just think about
our country our country is begging for
leadership yeah and i think we had that
with trump i we don't have that with
this current administration uh
and we're paying the price we're paying
the price
i think in a lot of ways desantis is
better but i don't know if desantis
would come in and do the you're fired
thing that that's that's the big issue
right yeah so with with ron desantis
he's proven his leadership in florida
he's done a really great job and i think
he'd be a fantastic president i'm not so
sure on foreign policy that's had to be
seen
but
i'd imagine if he did get in if he were
to win in 2024 if he ran and won
he would not go you're fired and he
would not get rid of all these really
awful people i think trump
he knows he's learned his lesson and he
was like i trusted some bad people if he
if he gets in 2024 it is going to be
beautiful as the pink slips start
getting handed out and then you see
people walking out of the of the the
buildings in dc and going into the the
unemployment line
i think trump's going to do i don't
think desantis would do it who would
have ever thought
our country could be destroyed in 17
months
17 18 months he's destroyed this country
so it's going to take a full four years
of donald trump to come back and try to
fix these issues and and oil and gas is
so important in texas and you know now
you have five dollar fuel inflation
eight and a half percent so i i love uh
oh sorry i i was gonna say i i just love
the the the
the meme where um the left says
joe biden doesn't control gas prices
idiot but joe biden's going to enact
policies to lower gas prices right yeah
it's like what do you what so can you
did he enact policies to make them
higher no but he can make them lower
okay dude whatever well and so i i try
to keep
a sort of a larger perspective and so
you know under the obama administration
i remember thinking like i really really
don't like obama but you know we had fdr
we had woodrow wilson maybe obama isn't
the worst president we've had joe biden
may actually be the worst president in
all of american history i mean at least
the really really bad ones like wilson
and fdr knew what day of the week it was
jimmy carter will appreciate that yeah
yeah jimmy carter i mean even carter i
would say i would say uh biden's worse
than carter grant i don't know as much
about jimmy carter but he's really bad i
mean there's something
usually when we rank a president we're
just sort of looking at them as a set of
policies that's what we seem to do
nowadays which is kind of bizarre
because this is a person who's supposed
to be a leader in character does mean
something when you're a leader
but with joe biden it's not just that
all of his policies have been horrible
for the country it's that
he
is experiencing serious cognitive
decline like the man's brain let's do it
let's do it we got this story from the
new york post oh you were so excited
you take your seat very specific cheat
sheet reminds button how to act look at
this
in this why did he hold it up i think in
order like you know you're the president
joe biden was speaking he was holding up
a card and it says you enter the
roosevelt room and say hello to
participants you take your seat like you
is in big bold letters and yours in big
bold letters like dude there's something
wrong with this guy's brain you tell
ukraine that the funds will be withheld
maybe someone played a joke on him at
number five was you hold card up to
camera and he's like okay all right here
we go come on man you know you think
about joe and and his cognitive you know
and i tell you what there's one person
that i'm really really frustrated with
and i think that
it's jill biden
listen she's been married to this guy
for years she knows him better than
anybody you're like throwing the power
well i'm just saying that you know what
i don't know if it she wanted to be the
first lady so bad and and have that
power or she wanted to make sure that
her husband reached that pinnacle but
i'm really frustrated with her because
she knows her husband better than
anybody and she knew he was going to be
like this but she didn't care and now
the american people are paying for this
thing because of what her because she
wanted to see her husband accomplish
something or maybe this was more about
her becoming you know the first lady but
uh she she
shameful
shameful i mean the democrats hated
trump so much i remember
everybody i used to hang out with we
weren't fans of biden biden was part of
the corporate left and suddenly these
same people were doing everything in
their power to elect a guy who they knew
we knew i didn't vote for him but we
knew would not be
good i didn't know it would be this bad
but yeah well clinton same deal it's
like we were
hating the clintons forever and now
you're acting like you're a sexist if
you're not going to vote for him occupy
wall street was anti-obama the people
down there were like obama's trash yep
and then it's like 2016 comes around and
they're like we've forgotten all about
that we like him though
hope and change baby yep yep yep yeah no
that's a very good point about joe biden
though i mean she should know right this
man has literally lost his mind is lost
it's just why did they pick it's insane
dr jill i'm sorry um
they used to joke about reagan and they
would say you know towards the end of
reagan's presidency he experienced some
cognitive decline and that was sort of a
little jab they'd make it republicans
look a person you elected back when they
were mentally healthy ended up
experiencing cognitive decline how
irresponsible is your party that he
wasn't immediately removed from power
during the primaries
joe biden was clearly demented or
suffering with alzheimer's
his brain was not functioning at like
any point and i i say this like look if
i was discussing any other senior
citizen
experiencing cognitive decline i would
probably take a more somber approach to
this like but this is the president they
knew this they put the man in this
position knowing his brain
does not work stop being aegis and
ableist sheamus
i know you're wrong no we're trying to
defend them oh that's true yeah whenever
they show like obama and they're like
this is how he looked in the beginning
of his presidency and then they show him
with gray hair it's like yo joe biden
started looking rough where does that go
yeah sheamus you're right i mean this is
the leader of the free world yeah that
we have as our president united states
and the media covers for him you know i
mean we have gas at five bucks i mean
i've said it how many times and he's
taken b walks on the beach but he's got
to have his handlers if it's not the
bunny rabbit during easter it's the
grandchildren and the other saying come
on honey we got to go we got to pull you
over here let me
real quick i want to give a shout out to
the onion
from this article oh stress of
presidency already ages but in 10 years
oh my god
you gotta give them where credit
is
he should really be ashamed of this
inflation and gas being five bucks again
i think it was like two cents a gallon
when he was a kid right
they were still dinosaurs when he was a
kid to be fair they were still walking
around yeah yeah yeah had been crushing
the crude oil but no it's shameful it's
dinosaurs aren't oil sheamus i know it's
the plant life and that was uh but
people say don't you know we don't
support the fake news on this show i
know you're right
thank you thank you ministry of truth
you're gonna sing a musical about it
yeah exactly he's very my joke was that
i didn't mean to spread misinformation
about oil i'm saying that joe biden is
old all right
okay he's old everybody but don't boom
tim is getting on me for being
factually inaccurate when i'm morally
correct well i was reading snopes
earlier and i was just thinking like i
shouldn't let shamus get away with these
jokes this misinformation this
misinformation yeah no it's it's
troubling and i think you know there's
something to be said for the fact that
no joe biden is not the sole culprit
here but he was part of the
establishment that led to all of these
problems it's not like he's just some
fall guy who had nothing to do with this
that that card he's holding up we are
literally in weekend at biden's i know
yeah what it is
they're they're holding up
someone would just like it
wouldn't it be funny if someone was
always standing next to him just like un
unreasonably close
what's going
what was his one word that described
america do you remember this
there's one word that describes it it's
the book
guys maybe that's why he's getting so
close to the kids as the kids are
whispering him as lines he forgot oh i
see what it is so there you go i figured
it out you're welcome joe biden i like
that let's see the the press secretary
tell us that oh here we go it's
something that they can yeah
here we go here we go hold on guys this
is important it's very important
america's oh wait i gotta fix it
i always have the audience after the
wrong thing because you guys need to
know oh you guys need to hear there we
go you ready
that can be defined in a single word
i was gonna put him
and then he ends up saying and then he
ends up saying at the foothills of the
himalayas
in a single word
i was going to put him
what
oh this poor old guy
here's the thing and i would feel bad
yeah i would feel bad for him if like
all right first of all if he wasn't a
horrible person doing horrible things
who should have stepped down
and also if you saw like we were being
gaslit about this he's got the he has a
speech impediment excuse me that's what
a lisp does no wrong incorrect his brain
is not functioning
also he's a plagiarist some british
politician probably had this gaffe first
that'd be funny why why are they even
talking about a second term though yeah
he's actually i don't think he's denied
it no he's he's claiming he's gonna run
yeah so think about that now that the
current condition he's in in another
three years insane that is insane yes
are they just hoping that this country
is so tribalized that people will vote
for him well that's what happened the
first time
well the first time people hated trump
maybe they're hoping they can do a
repeat but i really doubt it i think the
five bucks per gallon thing really irked
some people yeah
like the joke i was making earlier i
really doubt you're gonna go to a gas
station and someone's gonna be like
screaming and it turns out they're
screaming over january january 6th yeah
no it's it's a cedar for hamilton
there's no there's there was actually
breaking news uh biden plagiarized his
gaffe from a british politician the one
thing we can say about england
and nana
trinidad has shopped at a pressure
international under pressure
true to nash pressure do you remember
that remember remember that one troy no
i can't say i have but i i do know this
is that
they actually feel that uh that he has a
chance when he comes back i really
believe that uh that if he would seek
another term
and if you look at what happened with
the election in 2020 and the way that
thing was handled and managed and you
get started giving everybody ballots and
yeah
you could see i mean
i i i wasn't afraid i'll need an
effective strategy to mobilize true
international pressure oh boy i wish i
was getting an effective strategy to
mobilize true international average of
pressure now the best part is they're
clapping like when he says it yes we
need turner to shop at a pressure he
said batacaf care yeah he's loud there
he's trying to demonstrate strength by
yeah very vocal and like he's a hard
charger they probably think he's now
wrestling saw that he's like i can have
ukraine next now wrestling battle caf
care should have done a shot of the
pressure and a certificate they probably
think it's new progressive terms and
they don't want to get in trouble if
they don't clap it's like latina x
they're like okay that's a new one it
doesn't end in a shape
so he created a new incomprehensible
language
old man is just up there
muttering to himself and people are
clapping for it yeah that's why i'm like
i don't know i'm kind of i'm kind of a
pessimistic on this one he's the
american baby the american people are
going to vote for that
that's scary well the polls have shown
what is he 32-33 percent
and so the real question is
the way 30 i got to talk to those i know
i know that's right i don't know about
the 32 percent are they where are they
and what are they thinking i yeah i
cannot imagine 30 percent of the country
you know yeah this guy's doing a great
job they don't drive cars they're the
ones who are all working at the
mainstream media we should we should do
a bit
where you know jamie's just like i
actually i actually think trinidad shout
out to pressure is a good thing yeah
what is that like it's a good thing it's
a it's a great thing that's a great
thing and it's uh it's diversive and bad
at calf care we love better care better
i've i've always supported medical care
you know i mean what noam chomsky talked
about out of business here
supported it then i'll support it now
but i wonder if just like how do they
answer this do they act like it doesn't
exist yeah well no they they say he has
a speech impediment he has a lisp that's
what they constantly claim when people
make fun of him
yes yeah also that's scary again
commander in chief of the military
probably shouldn't be mislabeling
countries like that a little bit
frightening
he's going to be talking to the joint
chiefs but we got to bomb libya and
they're like are you sure yeah and then
they're like okay
and then later they're like why are why
is the us engaged in a military conflict
in libya and biden's gonna be like oh no
i meant syria
the media the media corrects for him
they they translate for him they're like
they're like they're like we dropped the
bomb on libby's like go pick it up man
put it drop on siri instead biden why'd
you sniff that kid i have a lisp yeah
come on man he has a lisp but you
heartless person yeah they will like
scold you for is hilarious that people
have been scolded for criticizing him uh
i can't remember who this was it was on
one of these news networks you know
msnbs or cnn or whatever and they're
going to how how how do you think
children with lisps are going to feel
when they see the way you're making fun
of the president or they're the the
potential president for the way he
speaks he's like what that's not no a
lisp does not make you say poor kids are
just as bright and talented as white
kids that's not how a lisp works
well well uh
now according to the dsm-6
let's go to super chats if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and
share the show with your friends as a
member you'll get access to as a member
at timcast.com you'll get exclusive
access you'll get access to exclusive
segments from the tim castle podcast i'm
pulling at joe biden
go to tipcast.com be a member we're
gonna have that special episode up for
you at 11 pm as we always do and uh your
membership helps us support uh help
support the expansion we got
documentaries coming all that good stuff
all right let's read some super chats
matthew wreck camp says new report on
yvaldi i swear the more i hear about
what those officers did or more
specifically didn't do the more i'm
convinced they should be charged not as
accessories but as accomplices
i was saying this before i was saying
either on accident or on purpose they
helped this guy it's great because they
were stopping people
daryl lyon says first and obligatory and
obligatory civil war
all right
that is not the first micro sapple says
you never told us about the anti-ben
shapiro doorknob oh yeah so when we got
uh
we had to evacuate because we had a
credible threat and so we turned on the
wide shot and people notice the door
knob is at the top of the door
and it's actually for a really simple
reason so that it's not in the camera
frame
on the show
uh but people we're calling it the
anti-bench shapiro doorknob
because it's very tall that's not right
but
but not right but these are people who
are like fans of ben shapiro okay but uh
but smart guy smart guy but i will say
this
when uh uh i i i'll tell you this when
you see all these memes where they're
saying like ben is five four five five
i actually believed it
and then i met him and he's like just a
little bit shorter than i am and i'm
five ten and so he's like five eight or
something well jamie you look up to him
he's taller than me yeah i was furious
when i found him
i can still beat him up but i'm still
not happy he doesn't have ears like you
he doesn't have ears no sir thank you
sir yes sir back we were uh i was
talking with jamie and then you said
something like him being shorter
actually he's kind of he's like average
size he's like he's like five eight and
a half or something and you're like he's
taller than me i was like i guess i am
below average size cool dude i gotta say
your fans i've been interact i've been
interacting more on twitter than i
usually do or my mental health scissors
should your fans are even when they're
like poking fun at me legitimately the
funniest fans i've ever met with they're
hysterical good engagement good
engagement
all right let's see what do we got i'm
not your buddy guy says you've mentioned
the shadow campaign numerous times when
analyzing did you ask yourself if
signature verification is removed what
would this cause also why trust barr
when he's the same man who said epstein
offed himself and oversaw doj when
epstein abused children hold on what
does all of that mean buddy
it's a it's a bit esoteric uh it's this
is one of the biggest challenge with all
of these big stories especially with
epstein is the average person doesn't
know about it so i would say the shadow
campaign was a time magazine article
where they claimed that a bunch of
powerful interests got together to
defeat donald trump in 2020.
uh if they remove signature verification
it would mean that there would be a
higher
uh rate of acceptance among mainland
votes
and why trust bar
i don't not a big fan
but what what what more can i say i
think we want to focus on encouraging
people to vote
especially now in the midterms
demoralization and telling people
you know that there's there's widespread
front stuff it's just going to make it
it's going to convince people not to be
involved
tell people to just go out and vote
because no matter what voting helps your
side it helps your eff
it's just you got to do it you got to do
it um my view of that just without you
know beating a dead horse the shadow
campaign talked about the legal efforts
they took you may not like what they did
i certainly don't but it was clever
lawfare over a year it wasn't weird
stories about the cia in germany and
like watermarked ballots or chinese
bouts or anything like that i think it
was just they pulled out all the stops
and said what legal hurdles do we need
to overcome to make sure we get as many
ballots in for our guy and they did it
and it worked for them
i genuinely believe people voted for joe
biden because people did not like donald
trump
all right well let's just you know read
some more super chats
matthew thomas says i'm getting real
tired of the republicans holding the
moral high ground if they don't return
in kind when they get power i'll only
vote libertarian from here out dems can
contested every election lost is isn't
that true like every single republican
election over the past like trump
stopped six they were objected to three
back to bush they objected to three yeah
they certainly did
which is a threat to our democracy by
the way it goes without saying that's
right yeah well their democracy is is
not that's that's why they say this
because when they do it's not a threat
to their democracy it empowers it our
constitutional republic
this is a threat to our constitutional
republic
yes
heather v says hey tim hired him back
how did the interview with vice go lol
enjoying you on cascasa
[Laughter]
look if you watch the vlog
um while i've said i've been having a
good time here on the podcast
would i like to be hired back at some of
these left-leaning places that aren't
taking my calls uh you know
watch the vlog and find out did i
briefly think that vice wanted an
interview if you want to watch the first
episode of the vlog i believe it is
called woke journalist tries to cancel
transphobic skater to work advice and
did i think it worked maybe did i curse
off the staff and leave the house saying
i'm never coming back and was it a setup
by vice perhaps again i would go to
youtube.com
castle and catch up on the vlog
i'm happy to be here tonight but that's
mainly just because i'm drinking
here's a good one this is crazy
gatorbate says my facebook was shut down
by facebook and was memorialized due to
someone reporting my account saying i
was dead
is that considered a death threat wow
wow that's crazy
they just memorialize your page and
you're alive
can you imagine getting a notification
being like sorry you're dead you're like
is this happening i don't think they'd
give you one i think they'll just shut
it down and lock you out and be like
because you're dead sorry you died wow
you know the creepiest thing is they're
talking about using your facebook
profile to create an ai chat bot of you
no yeah so like your grandpa dies and
then you can go on facebook and talk to
your grandpa and it'll give you answers
it'll learn from what you tell it and it
will speak back based on its memories
and photos and comments and all that
stuff and your grandfather will say i
think you should purchase nabisco
products because
the great advice i always get from pops
facebook is good can you can your
grandpa vote
oh yeah that's the question
and then he says something like you know
in my time here i've realized mark
zuckerberg is a pretty cool guy
you're like gee grandpa i've never heard
you say that before stop getting mad at
him for building he's not in hawaii it's
not actually a chatbot behind the other
side it's mark zuckerberg and he's
typing
zuckerberg rules he is great he is a
handsome boy
all right
gage gosnell says nebraska here would
love to see a tim cast shooting range
might even be better if you name it
after a rhino in the area
x uh ben's gas shooting range what is
that
oh an example i see
well i don't know we we wanted to
arrange but uh it's actually pretty
difficult you'd imagine yeah yeah it's
it's not just about having the land it's
about
i don't want to be responsible for
really dumb people yeah yeah exactly so
it's like we'll probably have the some
form of a range but it's not going to be
like any kind of substantial one or
anything like that west virginia is
awesome though because you know i was
talking to the cops and i was like how
does it work we're shooting and they're
like what do you mean and i was like you
know like on your property you want to
go shoot and they're like what do you
mean and i was like well are there like
rules they were like just don't hit
somebody
they're like yeah the only rule is
you're required to shoot yeah they were
like you mean you're not shooting on
your property and i'll be like no like
come with me sir and then yeah like
what's happening no but they're
basically just like have sufficient
backstop
make sure you're not
you know you don't injure anybody
because it's going to be on you you're
responsible for whatever happens but
there's nothing stopping you from
shooting on your property i am a huge
i've been a huge advocate of uh the
staff here going on shooting field trips
and also all learning jujitsu and just
turning into animals yes there's a
there's a public range up on the
mountain
not too far yeah yeah so it's it's
actually really cool because you'll go
out there and you'll hear shots and you
it's like actually it's a really good
spot it's a massive like 25 30 foot
backstop
and there there's like a straight path
to it so you don't accidentally walk in
you can see people and then you'll go
there and you'll see people it's really
really cool you'll hang out and
we saw some some guy with his son he had
a mini 14 and we were like oh cool and
then he's giving us good pointers they
were zeroing the sights and everything
was fun the one thing though is the cost
of ammo got so high
that people weren't coming out as much
you know i think we should do that one
day the four of us should go out and
whoa oh absolutely
i can't speak this is uh this is the
congressman's real attitude i have
within the couple hours i've known him
seen him challenge someone to pool
almost wrestle me and now challenge me
he is ready to go until i saw your ears
now jamie yeah
he back down with the wrestling yeah all
right all right we got chris pavetto
says
my seven year my seven-year-old son has
down syndrome why are red states slow to
fund special therapies and services with
medicaid for family members needing
assistance while blue states fund more
texas needs more family support i did
research
this because moving to texas please help
well and i feel horrible about that and
i think we certainly should help
america's families that have children
with special needs uh so uh the only
thing i could say is is uh please reach
out to my office i don't know where you
live i don't know what district you're
in but uh you can please uh reach out to
my office and and we'll do what we can
to address that issue i don't have an
answer for you right now but i think
it's it's good that we could engage we
should engage
all right idg says shelly moore crepito
and other senators can be recalled by
state legislatures the way the founders
intended if we repeal the 17th amendment
um keep that on billboards and you will
shake up the uniparty
yeah so um
you know the 17th amendment right yeah
go ahead yeah we used to have it used to
be that the state legislature would
would vote they would appoint the
senators who would go up to the federal
government and then for a variety of
reasons
namely what they said was fear of
corruption
because legislature legislators would
then be like i'll do a favor for you i
can do what i want they switched it to
the popular vote i think that was a
mistake i think it's only made things
worse
i think the that if we were if our
senator was based on the state
legislatures
people would be more paying attention to
their state races to their local
elections which is substantially more
important for where you live than
federal elections
all right let's read some more
what do we have here
s r dempsey says can republicans get an
inventory of all who are inside of
congress on one sex and their
affiliation it seems more than just
trump supporters were inside that
building that's true
at least one guy and a woman were
leftists they claimed they're just
they're documenting they didn't get
charged or anything like that but i
wonder who else
yeah i think you're going to find that
that uh that there were other groups
there they weren't all trump supporters
there you're going to find antifa i mean
you could sit here and i know you guys
know the name ray epps and the scaffold
commander but ray yepps he still hasn't
been arrested so there's a lot of
questions that need to be asked but
you're not getting it from this j6
committee
you're going to get it from us though
you're going to get it from the five of
us that are on this shadow committee and
and i talk about it in my book right on
all rights peas and butter says how do
we know you will use your red wave win
wisely what is your five to ten year
plan what is your 2023 agenda
well this is what i do know is that
there's 435 of us and every two years we
get out there and we stomp in our
districts and we're going to tell their
people the conservatives like myself
that we're going to reduce taxes we need
less government we need to get the less
regulation get the government out of our
business
and then many of us get elected and then
many of us get up here and we either do
nothing or do just the opposite and i'm
not one of those guys that's why i i'm
proud to be part of that freedom caucus
because i stay true to myself i stay
true to my voters and believe it or not
what that does for me is i can sleep
with a clear conscience and i sleep like
a baby as a result
yeah we like the freedom caucus guys we
do yeah you know uh i i like when
marjorie taylor green and thomas massey
were talking about how they they have
somebody on rotation to make sure that
whenever there's a vote they call all
the congress people to come and actually
vote on it
so
a lot of people didn't know this until
we had marjorie taylor green on that a
lot of the votes on bills are like just
proxy it's like there's a handful of
democrats republicans and they're just
like and then no one actually comes in
and votes on these bills in congress
so when uh when she mentioned that she
calls for a floor vote to make everyone
come down people were cheering like make
them do their jobs yeah they call that
the roll call vote there's been a lot of
proxy voting because of covid uh i think
uh when we take over the house i think
elena mccarthy will will do away with
the proxy voting cool
all right where we got tasty waffle says
tim can you clarify what the 2a scotus
ruling will mean for people especially
in california do we now get
constitutional carry nationwide haven't
sat down to read it yet
no
brett kavanaugh said states that require
permits for handguns can still do so
this ruling will not affect them sorry
thanks kavanagh clarence thomas said
requiring someone to state a reason as
to why they should defend them need to
defend themselves is a violation of the
second amendment and the 14th so this
should impact california that they have
to re they are required
if they're going to have a concealed
carry permit that i believe they
basically have to know
if you can uh check all the boxes off on
their criteria they have to give you the
permit so that's that's fascinating and
and your right extends outside the home
so this is big as well
so you can walk around with that
concealed carry so long as you get your
permit or you can move to texas or west
virginia and you don't need one hey
congressman can i actually ask you a gun
question too when it comes to
lefty talking points that i'm sure there
is a counter to that i've never heard in
my life when it comes to background
checks or issues like this that happen
with the supreme court are those also
far more or far less effective than
people on the left think where we think
maybe it'll solve everything if there is
a longer waiting period if there are
stricter background checks red flag laws
and things like that does that actually
help or is it just
well i don't know jamie i think that 72
hours is reasonable i do know that
people that have gone to purchase a
firearm that had a background check have
been denied for one reason or another so
no i think the background checks are are
effective i mean i know firsthand
because i've talked to people that have
been rejected for one reason or another
and maybe it was a criminal offense
maybe even 20 25 years ago and then i
have to work through that process so i
believe the background checks are a good
thing and i think the american people
support him thanks all right captain
tanker joe says
i think the diesel shortage is going to
be worse than expected i've seen fuel
jump 10 to 15 cents overnight i've seen
videos of people saying they've been
they've been stopped for days waiting
for fuel already the shortage is
starting already i'm afraid i did see
some tweets from people saying that some
gas stations have run out of gas
it could just be because sometimes gas
stations run out of gas
however we are hearing a lot in the news
that is going to be a diesel shortage
and that's going to result in food
prices going through the roof because
farmers need diesel to actually tend the
crops to harvest so it's going to have a
massive ripple effect
uh
a lot of people tell me never to say
this but i just bought more emergency
food just you know full disclosure i did
got these buckets they last 25 years
because my worst case scenario is uh
well the worst case scenario is i guess
the apocalypse happens you need to eat
them the best case scenario is you got
fuji's eat it anyway they're pretty good
yeah
all right
wandering mage says during the house
judiciary meeting on the omnibus gun
control rep nadler went ballistic at the
idea of raising the draft age he yelled
about national security but it felt like
he sees us as his toy soldiers and the
draft
oh jerry
i i i didn't i didn't hear what he had
to say i have no comment because i don't
i'd have to get more information on that
but jerry nadler is is an interesting
fella he is the chairman of the
judiciary um
i've tried to work with him to get some
legislation to his committee because
folks if you don't understand if you
want to get anything on the house if you
want to get some a vote on the house
floor you got to go through the the the
committee of jurisdiction i've tried to
do some things in crime law enforcement
related matters criminal justice reform
and jerry lander just doesn't want to
hear any of it so uh i don't have a
whole lot of love for him because i just
i think he's out of tune and out of
touch oh yeah i remember when he said
antifa was just an idea or whatever
all right rory f says rep nails are you
re-electing mccarthy as majority leader
why or why not i see a lot of lobbyist
money that's also going to the dccc and
major dem bills you know that's a great
question and uh we were talking about
that the other day and i i'm a realist
and and i'm telling you right now that
leader mccarthy has raised an enormous
amount of money it's a record amount of
money uh to help get uh uh the majority
um and and there is no other answer
leader mccarthy i'm telling you right
now kevin mccarthy is going to be the
speaker of the house um and that's it so
now we just have to do everything we can
to try to hold him accountable we must
hold him accountable but he doesn't want
to impeach if the american people i
don't know if he does want to or not but
if if the american people and you are
going to give us the gavel back we have
to take care of it because republicans
are sick and tired of this when we had
both chambers of congress when we had
paul ryan we had both chambers we had
donald trump what did we do for a
southern border we didn't do a damn
thing donald trump had to do it on his
own through executive order so i just
think that uh that the republican party
better be very very careful that if we
don't take care of that gavel and do
right for the american people and start
putting the american people first we're
going to end up giving it right back and
we're going to lose the confidence of
the american people
i think i think mccarthy said he didn't
want to impeach biden i think that was
his stance i'm not i'm not i'm not a big
fan i'm i'm not confident that if he
becomes speaker of the house we're going
to see a lot of change i think it'll be
it'll be once again republican slow
rolling
democrats go on the speed limit i'd like
to see uh
thomas massey that speaker of the house
yeah that'd be a whole lot of fun
but uh at the same time
there's the challenge of
do you take what you can get or what do
you do i think there's a lot of people
hearing hearing that it would be
mccarthy would probably vote libertarian
instead because there's just the
confidence in in the republican
leadership is just
the freedom caucus is great but
but we'll see man we'll see
all right let's see alex bradley says
criminals can 3d print pistols with an
internet connection and 300 bucks why is
this even a discussion just educate yup
you can 3d print guns
crazy plastic and a and like a nail or
whatever i feel like every time i'm on
the show i learned something that i
didn't know that's going to give me
nightmares i haven't seen one have you
guys seen one oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i haven't i have to be control pew
there are three three printed gun
advocates and they post videos of all
the time all the time you look at these
videos of 3d printed guns and you're
like wow
no joke they're well designed it's crazy
some of them require more metal parts
than others the uh the first i believe
was the liberator and it was like a sing
it was it was basically a single shot
nine millimeter or something but they've
advanced the technology of
three-dependent grunt printed guns where
they've got like
um people have been telling me like
almost entirely uh you know
plastic-based 3d printed you got like 3d
printers have come a long way plus
there's also cnc machines so it's really
easy to make guns at home not to mention
there are those videos that guys have on
youtube where they take like two pipes
i'm not gonna say much beyond that but
like literally two pipes and there's a
shotgun so
you know i don't know i don't know man
man we grew up digging for the anarchist
cookbook that was our big thing we
didn't have 3d printers or guns
these days
yoder says tim ian and you guys need to
look up the battle of athens tennessee
1946 oh yeah yeah we were familiar
justification that we need to
uh 2a to defend ourselves against
tyrannical government it would really be
cool if you guys did a documentary on
this that would be cool i don't think i
don't know if it would be a full doc
it'd be a short doc mini doc maybe but
uh the battle of athens you guys know
about it no veterans came back from
world war ii and the town was corrupt
and taken over so they
basically reclaimed the town really oh
that should be a move that's i was going
to say you can't make a documentary
who would play the leading role i mean
obviously the very tall and handsome
jamie hill scene
tina colette says why does no one ever
point out the two teens who got gunned
down in the chase were running for
safety from just having been just having
carjacked the jeep they were driving
running
for from just having carjacked they
stole the jeep and then they got shot
and killed
i don't know man
you know
if if washington and oregon were like we
want to secede from the union i'd be
like hey don't let me stop you you know
like you guys do your thing california
man they got a lot of food but
yikes
what's going on in those states
the prophet says obama loves hot dogs
it's from chicago people don't
understand this in those emails that got
leaked obama was like i'm gonna order
thirty thousand dollars of the hot dogs
a pizza flying in for a party and then
people were like that must be code for
something because it makes no sense and
i'm like dude he's talking about
portillos
and giordano's or or maxwell street and
lumonadis but we it's funny i always say
this i'm always like yeah we just
ordered i think we ordered a thousand
dollars in pizza and hot dogs from from
chicago to come here for a party
because it's you ordered giordano's
online famous chicago deep dish and
portillo's hot dogs they're amazing it's
celery salt pickles
maybe he's doing it for mega month with
us yeah well this was back like they had
a party at the white house and everyone
thought it was a grand conspiracy and
i'm like dude if a guy from chicago is
having a party for all of his friends
and he spends 30 grand to fly out this
expensive food
he's rich
he's flying out famous chicago do you
like chicago hot dogs that's cool oh bro
you don't understand chicago has no i
know i know some there was a there was a
couple restaurants that were like some
of the most notable restaurants in the
country for selling hot dogs it was
crazy they had like ostrich and eel hot
dogs and they had like foie gras hot
dogs
it's crazy chicago's got food yeah and
then you got the famous maxwell street
you know maxwell street you get the
polish sausage with the mustard and the
onions on it and then you've got
lumnati's you got giordano's you got
uno's oh man pizza pizza no i'm hungry
right now yep yep we've got a whole
bunch of giordano's downstairs thrown in
what it's really good they don't set it
with the sauce packets though anymore oh
that's the economy and and it looks like
they're putting a layer of crust on top
of the cheese yeah it's not it's not as
it's not as good
they've had to make them cheaper or
something i think that's what it's
happening yeah yeah so we were ordering
for a while and deep dish pizza is like
a big layer of cheese with sauce on top
and you get a sauce pack to make it
saucier
now there's no sauce pack and it looks
like there's a layer of dough on top
we gotta just like get our own sauce or
something i don't know man can you can
you guys fix that if you win
you can't
yeah i mean unfortunately having lived
the growing up there i'm not sure that
you can it's like 80 years of democrat
leadership and people just don't learn
what you get they're like i voted for
the democrat last time and everything's
worse
i'm gonna vote for a democrat again
i love chicago yeah
all right let's just grab a couple more
of these super chats
all right what do we got
daniel brent says the police have no
responsibility to protect us they will
sit back while children are murdered
yvaldi and parkland compromised
institutions filled with cowards just
like the gop
wow
listen i you know that i don't think
that's very fair i i
most of us uh that have served in this
business for 30 years yes we're
questioning the judgment of those
officers and and uh they're going to
have a lot to live with there's no
question about it i i don't know what
they were thinking i know they were
trying to listen to the chief of police
or something but it would have been hell
or high water i would have gone in there
no matter what and you're taught in
alert training everyone's taught in
alert training that when you get to an
active shooter scene you go in even if
you're by yourself i don't care if you
have a vest or a shield or a shotgun or
whatever you go in and they chose not to
wow and they're going to have to live
with that and and i i think it's it's
horrible i didn't i didn't agree with
their their actions and but i i don't
think it's fair to to paint this all uh
in that type of a light the story that
came out oh sorry well there was a story
that came out today i think it came out
today about the
husband or boyfriend who was armed and
was stopped by the police who wanted to
go in and save his wife or girlfriend
who was killed was just
gutting well that guy was going to be a
hero he was going to go be a hero and
save his wife one last one and it's a
good one gnarly marley says if you claim
to be for gun rights why you're not
actively trying to abolish the nfa well
i'll phrase that in a question for uh
you congressman would you be in are you
in favor of abolishing the nfa
the national firearms act
no
you're not
i i would have to uh
do more research research on it all i do
know is i support the second amendment
this legislation coming across uh from
the senate uh to my it may be tomorrow
it may not be tomorrow uh but i won't
support it i don't believe uh that you
know if we want to do everything we can
to try to help prevent shootings and
protect our children as we should my
wife's a principal of an elementary
school we need to harden our schools we
need to put law enforcement officers in
our school trained law enforcement
officers in our school as well so i
think that's a step in the right
direction but i think it's sad that the
left every time you have a tragedy like
this take place they try to exploit
those deaths and they then they try to
trample on people like me and my rights
uh as an american citizen the the nfa
basically
makes it prohibitively expensive for
people to get short short barreled
rifles suppressors and select fire
rifles well i i listen i i support the
idea of having suppressors in because i
have such hearing loss now and so i i
think that uh listen i support the
second amendment and uh and and i will
continue to do so um and and i don't
believe that our government uh should
should be toying with this and playing
with this i tried buying suppressors and
i haven't been able to get them because
it's it's it's literally impossible
because of the nfa so the requirements
to actually get an nfa item for me
would require me to stop working and so
i get it like it's my choice to run a
company
but because of the rules set forth and
the amount of time it takes i'm not i'm
not able to get them i think i should be
able to go into a gun store and say i'll
take one suppressor please and they hand
it to me and they put in a box and
that's it it's an accessory but because
of the nfa i'm never going to be able to
get one yeah i i've been doing this 30
years and and i've been to many many
crime scenes i've never been to a scene
in 30 years where anybody has used a gun
to go out and kill somebody that's had a
suppressor on it realize they don't want
suppressors don't actually make it sound
like pew pew like in the movies right i
understand that's what they say it's all
movie stuff no it's true like they base
their gun policy on what they see in
movies there's not double 07's running
around our country with suppressors
shooting people that sounds like double
seven talk to me but anyway it's
actually funny when you put it that way
it's like that is not who we're trying
to stop right now i'll keep arguing for
repealing the nfa and the hughes
amendment and restoring all those gun
rights but uh we'll we'll wrap it up
here if you haven't already smash that
like button subscribe to this channel we
are going to have more coming up for you
at timcast.com it will go up at about 11
p.m it's our members only show
uncensored not family friend we got a
lot more to talk about and so you can
follow the show at tim cast irl you can
follow me at tim cast congressman would
you like to shout anything out yes uh if
i could i've enjoyed this this has been
great uh thank you for all the listeners
and and i'd like to uh uh plug my book
uh nails and ehls with an s nails for
congress.com and pressing the pre-order
uh my book located in the main menu it
talks about january 6 my activity's
there talks about the summer riots talks
about 2020 election and everything else
and i think you would really really
enjoy it it's an easy read with pictures
oh good right
i need those because i'm a cartoonist
and speaking of witch i make cartoons a
youtube channel called freedom tunes we
just released one today i think you guys
will really like it it's about the woke
christian inquisition we also just
launched a website to help us get
independent from platforms like patreon
and other big tech platforms so
freedomtunes.com become a member five
bucks a month get an extra cartoon every
week and help support us get independent
from big tech thank you very much
uh you guys can follow me on twitter at
jamiekillstein on instagram at the jamie
killstein legitimately the conversations
i've been having with all of you
have been the most fun i've had in a
very long time being in the public space
so i appreciate it whether you agree or
disagree with me you can check out a uh
the podcast at jaimekillsteinpodcast.com
it's called a f-ups guide to the
universe where we talk about mental
health a lot tribalism uh just being a
good person and also admitting to your
flaws giving advice all that kind of
stuff and then this saturday at the
beacon theater you can see me and tim
tulsi gabbard ian uh
zooby james o'keefe all sorts of people
from the left and the right um debate do
stand-up comedy it's a really important
event and if we can pack this out we can
have more events and i don't work for
that company for minds but they can have
more events that promote free speech
that promote uncensored comedy ryan
long's also going to be doing stand up
who's hysterical so that's uh saturday
the beacon theater you can get tickets
or apply for free tickets at
festival.minds.com
yeah it's gonna be a lot of fun there's
also gonna be tyler fisher and chrissy
marr doing comedy between the panels i
believe it's gonna be
so awesome i'm really looking forward to
it never been to new york city i'm about
to change that and i'm hoping well it's
your first time yeah oh that's amazing
no i'm really excited it's gonna be a
really fun time i'm hoping it lives up
to my expectations i'm sure it won't in
this economy anyway you guys can follow
me on twitter and mines.com at
sourpatchlids as well as
sourpatchloads.me there's also going to
be a vip meet and greet so i guess if
you go to the festival.mines.com
that's that's the url uh
festival.mines.com yeah that they
mention i think there's a there's a
there's a meet and greet happening for
vip tickets so if you want to get those
but for people who uh who can't afford
it there's a option to get free tickets
actually raymond g stanley jr just
mentioned in the super chat saying it
worked the free tickets actually awesome
so the idea is it's very expensive to
put on an event at the beacon theater
you got to understand that one of the
most historical theaters of all yeah
it's massive it's like 3000 seats and so
that's why the tickets cost what they do
but because of kovit you know we're
really trying to get as many people to
come out as possible so one of the
reasons that it is so expensive is
because they have great security so i'm
really not concerned so whatever happens
on friday happens on friday and then i'm
sure we'll be fine at the event so come
on down all right everybody we will see
you all over at timcast.com thanks for
hanging out bye guys
you